你再多比什么？
这个背景是一个形状造型非常具有代表性的雪山。
很多朋友应该这个如果对户外略有设列或者有兴趣的话，
你应该知道这就是所谓的宇宙中心这个弹幕。
康尔伯基
就是阿财富的位置。
先跟你们说我们现在在海拔4630米的康尔伯基的山脚下。
也是219国道1314这个叫借杯。
李承辈
这个李承辈现在就在我们场地外面20米。
哈喽朋友们
欢迎收听这期的基本无害加耿。
补耕算是
因为前段时间不是在外出拆脱耕了一下嘛？
所以我给大家补上。
如果你对康尔伯基转山感兴趣。
就是我感觉应该没有人能比我聊得更好。
因为我去年跟今年去康尔伯基转山转了两次。
今年是单人单日52公里。
去年的这个也是单日52公里。
但是跟朋友一块走了一半。
后来朋友这个半路下车了。
我自己走完了后半场。
加上我的这些相对比较丰富的高海拔经验。
户外经验
所以说我在这期节目。
应该我是比较自信能聊的。
比大多数人聊得更全面的。
这期节目呢？
要先感谢凯勒什
因为这期节目的原型。
其实是因为我跟凯勒什一块在康尔伯基山脚下。
做了一次直播
前段时间我不是说去西藏包。
我说今年又在康尔伯基单人单日转里程。
其实就是因为
大老远跑到康尔伯基做直播。
这个直播的背景是。
讲而言之
凯勒什就挺大动干葛。
不惜血本的
把我们几个运到
真的就是海拔4600多米的。
这个康尔伯基的山脚下一块。
做了一场直播
本来是说把这个直播的内容。
就直接发成一期播客了。
因为那个直播本身就。
内容很丰富
聊得也很干
但是我在直播完之后的第二天。
第三天
我自己又走了一圈。
我又多了很多感悟。
所以说我在想
加一些自己的独白。
把那些直播里面
没有机会展开的
没有聊明白的东西给它加上。
这样就能做成一期。
更丰富的节目
这期节目你接下来听到的。
就会是一个
原形式直播
但在直播的这个
实录的基础上
我又加了一些
自己的解读跟补充。
很多朋友是不是不知道。
就是凯勒什这个名字。
英文名
Kylish
我看他们好像
广告派对那个人都读。
Kylish
Kylish这个英文名。
就是钢人波琪这个山的英文名。
凯勒什这个牌子
起名字就是源于钢人波琪。
就我跟凯勒什也是老朋友了。
我们24年的时候就。
开始合作
然后今年也很感谢他们邀请。
他们教上了我和其他几位。
很有意思的嘉宾
一块在钢人波琪山脚下。
做了这次直播
有一个户外老炮
也是凯勒什的
培训部的负责人叫杨勇。
勇哥
还有一位是钢人波琪。
1314咖啡馆的。
竹立人叫刘行
他这个咖啡馆玩叫1314。
是因为山
门口就是219国道。
很有名的219国道。
然后219国道
有一个戒杯
公里数的戒杯
1314戒杯就是。
离钢人波琪最近的戒杯。
在1314戒杯旁边。
就开了这么一家咖啡馆。
也是当地比较有
地标性质的这么一个业态。
然后刘行是山东人。
几年前跑到钢人波琪。
开了一家咖啡馆
他可能是我们的
几个嘉宾里面
其实对这个山最了解的。
虽然他是汉族人
那走了好几十次
大几十次的转山路线。
然后最后一位嘉宾叫。
弹望
他是一个藏族同胞。
很年轻
现在还在上大学
但他上的是户外专业。
这个藏区的这些文化。
然后包括这些户外知识。
都非常了解
所以这次是我们四个人。
一块儿做的一场直播。
我自己当时反正还在说。
我觉得他们
凯勒士干这直播
其实还挺
挺为艺术的
还挺浪漫的
理论上
我们四个在哪儿都能聊。
钢人波琪
但是他非把这几个人。
就运到这个钢人波琪山脚下。
我们就在这个咖啡馆。
然后背后是那个落地窗。
然后落地窗外面
就是钢人波琪那个山。
我们在山际前面
做了一个将近
三四个小时的直播。
主题叫
从激发向往到安全抵达。
你听这个名字也能听出来。
就先跟大家聊一聊。
钢人波琪这个山
他诱人的地方
他的魅力
然后所以我跟大家讲讲。
这些
如果你要来转山的话。
来徒步的话
一些实操的经验
我先跟大家介绍
我呢是一个户外号者。
也是个特务线员
很多朋友听我的播客。
我又播客叫基本无害。
我叫毛东
有人叫毛书记
然后我身边这三位。
一位就是这个
我们现在所在的
1314咖啡馆的老板。
刘醒
大家好
我是1314的咖啡。
主力人刘醒
欢迎大家来到
这个山脚下
来到我们咖啡馆
对
我们习惯叫他醒哥。
其实醒哥年纪也没那么大。
比我跟泳哥要小一点。
江湖传号
然后这位传号
大家一看就能看出来。
咱们的藏族兄弟
我这两天玩的特别开心。
然后特别可爱
弹忘
现在打个招呼
哈喽大家好
我叫弹忘
我是出生在西藏的。
然后莫名之子
也是一个户外二号纸。
我现在在学户外
然后就是来到了这里。
欢迎大家来这里玩。
就是弹忘说他学户外。
大家别以为是说
是不是普通话不标准。
这个学户外
是不是没有这个说法。
人家正耳八经
真的在学户外
他的那个大学专业。
就是户外专业
对吧？
一会儿可以让弹忘。
详细给大家解释一下。
然后我们这位嘉宾。
泳哥
户外经历
20余年的户外老炮。
是咱们凯勒时
这个培训部的负责人。
大家好
我叫杨勇
公事统统就叫勇哥。
做户外整整快25年了。
没有
你是不是很难了
看你那年
我觉得你做户外
得三四十年了
没有
我典型的70后
70后
我们看完用
勇哥70后
我算是占了个
80后的尾巴
89年的
然后 醒哥是90。
90头
咱俩回去插几天
估计
当旺是00后
咱四个把这个
给占全了
我觉得醒哥
你先把自己的
故事介绍完
一个山东大汉
来到了西藏
开个咖啡馆
行
我大概简单介绍一下。
来西藏
来这个地方之前
我是在内地
做了十几年媒体
然后基本上也是
经历了我们媒体的。
各个阶段的转型
从一开始的
电视媒体
到后来的直致媒体。
一直到网络媒体
基本上都做全了
然后干了十几年媒体之后。
就是有一天
也是所谓的职业平静。
也或者说
想追求一点不一样的生活。
完了之后
就开始到处走
那个时候
是几年前
我第一次来西藏
第一次来西藏的时候。
我就在拉撒族的一个车。
一路往西开
就开到了
我们现在
大概就坐的这个位置。
就是我们口
到了这个地方之后。
那是十几年前的事。
几年前
几年前的事
对
那个时候
我当时在这待了一下之后。
都觉得很喜欢
很喜欢
反应特别强烈
就搞反了
头痛欲裂
反应特别强烈
那是你第一次进藏吗？
第一次进藏
那个时候
我甚至不知道
我们后边这座山
叫什么名字
来了之后
就感觉挺好的
不过这人也很有善。
当时我不是
在门口躺着吗？
很多人来帮助我
当时大概躺了
一晚上之后
就觉得
既然找了这么多地方。
都找不到合适的地儿。
我觉得留在这
可能是一个
特别好的选择
你觉得命运的安排。
明明之中
对
然后就留在这
然后就回去
解决完内地的
大部分的一个工作。
然后走完交接
然后就直接来了
这是你第一次来
刚刚博弃的
其实是第二次
第一次在什么时候。
第一次是去年
去年这么快
去年因为
这个不瞒大家说
今天为啥小毛
有资格坐在这
跟这几位户外
不管是大佬
还是这个新秀一块儿。
聊
因为这几年
至少作为爱好者
也精进了
我去年是因为
抱了去爬木尔塔格。
然后为了
去给木尔塔格拉链。
有一个
户外的前辈
也建议我
他说你可以试试去。
走感人波棋
他说你尽量
一天内走完
去锻炼一下
自己在
特别叫
长时间疲惫状态下的。
行进的能力
当时我就5月份
应该来走过一圈
太棒了
然后也算是
其实我喜欢户外
也好多年了
今天之位能坐在这。
我很荣幸
其实很多朋友
我讲途舞秀
然后也是做内容
其实我
喜欢户外搞户外
应该是远远走
与我表达
做内容这些
只是我进步太慢了。
进步太慢了
但是慢慢
你不怕慢就化站
你看我不停
我慢慢的一点点精进。
最终还是能跟这几位。
非常优秀的户外人。
在一块儿聊
还是挺开心的
Anyway
这是
醒哥 刘醒
在
钢人波棋山脚下
开咖啡厅的故事
然后当旺
牧民的孩子
您刚自己说的
对
然后稍微的介绍一下。
我自己的一些
户外的
这个经验也好
或者就是
我为什么？
来这边的
一个缘故的话
第一个我就是
我觉得我就是
刚开始的时候
我们那边有一个景区。
叫宁静康山
宁静康山 很有名。
对
然后有好多人
来那里玩
当时我不知道
这个户外的概念
因为我觉得
我就是牧民嘛？
然后牧民的孩子
本来就是一个户外人。
我后面想
是这么一个回事
我打个叉
你说你牧民的孩子。
你家是有
牛跟羊的吗？
对
我们家里
你是大货
没有
也不算大货
你家有几千多毛牛。
你说吧？
没有
我去内地上学
然后
大家以为我家里有。
好多好多
其实我们家里
只有一百左右
不用透露
一百
这都已经
克制了
你是养牛还是养
养毛牛
然后我们去
我们养毛牛的话
有冬季牧场
下季牧场
这样的一个
转场
然后这个时候
我们也会翻到
不同的一些牙口
还是像
转山路线一样的
一些户外场景
昨天我跟
弹王聊
弹王提到了
他说他去走
咱们
咱们这个
高尔摩天路线
他说走起来的
其实有很多的亲切。
跟熟悉感
因为跟他
之前放牧的时候
冬牧场下牧场
签席特别像
对
你们那个时候
我猜海拔
应该会比较
稍微低一些
海拔也差不多
差不多
跟这里差不多
还有我们
冬季牧场
下季牧场
之前有
两个山要翻
所以就是
两个山的高度
和难度
也跟琢磨拉牙口
差不多
所以
所以我有很多
就是
我向往这边的原因。
一个就是
我们小的时候
就是
长辈们讲
这边有很多传说
然后我想听一听
我觉得
这个难度
也不是特别大
我就分了
两天时间
就是去
转这个山
反正就是
当时去转的时候
还是很有
这种
就是体验感
你说你那个
冬季牧场
牵细的时候
要翻两个山
我不知道
比如这个时候
是你和家人
几个人一块
反正一百头毛牛
走吗？
还是就一百人一个人。
还是全家都要牵细。
我们是这样
就是
我们
公毛牛
有二十多头
他们
他们形成一个舵队。
舵很多东西
然后
爸爸妈妈
前面走
像是我
还有弟弟
我们就是
爸爸妈妈
前面走
他们就是去
搭帐篷了
然后就是先
先赶
然后我们后面
慢慢的把那些
母牛啊？
小的那些毛牛
赶过去
就是这样一个
二十多公毛牛
在干活
背东西
对
就是舵队
舵毛牛
舵那个
舵东西
有点像
咱们这种
要帮你
去打伤工
下方呢？
先去把账户炸好
这个
这个过程
痛苦吗？
就是会遇到
然后
你们船家人也要
在风雨中行进的
这种状态
对
所以我后面
就是
稍微
怎么说嘛？
就是理论性的
接触这些
户外知识的时候
其实他就是
我自己的生活
原来的生活
就是我们
我们会经历
各种各样的
几段天级
对对对
泳哥
介绍介绍你的
户外经历
我的户外经历
然后一直到
现在
没离开过户外
这个行业
一天都没离开过
一直在这里面
就有跟我差异的
所以说你02年之前。
是你比如
毕业之后
就直接进入
户外行业
还是在那之前
干过别的行业
算是干过别的
但是
也就
没有兴趣
完全没兴趣
明白
很快就转到
这个户外行业
对很快
然后当时就是
我们家楼下
就一个很小的一个店。
因为当时
2000年初的时候。
就很小很小的
一个俱乐部
然后我就
最开始我就是
每天
上下班
经常走过那条线
我就那条路
我就感觉
这个
这个地方挺有意思的。
俱乐部
就是一个户外店
当时那个时候
不叫户外店叫俱乐部。
当时对那个时候
对这个
对这个词
理解没有那么深
而且如果我没记错。
领地前的时候
那个时候我虽然也是。
一个学生
但我很喜欢户外
那时候网上
大家还不怎么用
户外这个词
都叫什么？
然后他们当时
因为那个时候
他们的媒介
他就在他那个店的门前。
贴了很多照片
然后很多人背着大包。
出去玩
又点狗火
什么我感觉
我就看他们照片
我说这个挺有意思的。
然后就想有机会
我也跟他们出去玩。
或者怎么样
然后慢慢慢慢
真的就跟他们出去玩。
然后后来发现
其实这可以
当成一个事来做
你这等于说
从这个消费者
变成从来者了
然后就慢慢慢慢
各种集园巧合
然后就进入到他们。
这个
这个圈子
然后进入到
最初就是
在店里面慢慢货
然后慢慢发展到
平时带人出去玩
然后因为玩得
尽量多了以后
就会给他们策划一些。
比较有意识的一些路线。
一些各有趣的一些活动方式。
然后慢慢慢慢
随着工作不断的变化。
反正都是在这个行业里面。
然后05年就去了北京。
在北京整整10年。
也是住户外
刚好从05年开始。
其实0506
差不多0506年开始。
一直到1314年。
应该是中国户外的。
第一波浪潮起的时候。
国内基本上有差不多。
有2000多家的户外店和俱乐部。
就是爆发性的
然后到了差不多
15年之后
因为一些家庭原因。
就没办法需要照顾老人。
我就回了东北
然后在东北差不多。
一年多吧？
但这一年多
我也没有停下来说。
没有不做户外
我当时做了一个跑步俱乐部。
就是现在特别流行的。
跑团
不是跑团
现在特别流行的一个运动。
叫跑山
跑山
越野跑
所以那个时候
我就开始在组织一些。
当时因为10年左右的时候。
国内开始兴起
逐渐西湖跑山山
各个知名跑山山
开始兴起了
我也参加了一些比赛。
然后后来我感觉
其实这个事情可以做。
然后我当时在东北的时候。
其实也具备那些条件。
那我就做了这个事情。
但其实就是
可能我认为
这件事情挺好玩
但是很多
是一个市场的发展。
还有一些
其他的一些缘故
毕竟季节的原因
不像现在
现在你能看到的
各种各样的装备
气泄非常多
但那个时候
可能越野跑
刚刚兴起的时候
跑山山刚刚兴起的时候。
其实没有那么多东西。
也没有那么多装备给你。
一年四季都让你去干这个事情。
慢慢发展
那就没办法
就只能关掉
亏了一些钱
对
然后
也是捐巧合吧？
就跟我现在的老板。
也是做了一个
面对面的一个交流。
终身
你就应该来凯勒斯。
为啥
你俩怎么继承巧合。
他跟着你跑山去了。
没有
其实我们那个时候。
其实行业里面
其实
因为做的时间都比较久。
大家就是说
人不熟灭手
对吧？
所以就是说
还能有一些交流
都是户外老板
对
然后聊了一些
当时聊了一些
户外的一些想法
聊了一些理念
然后他就说
你应该来凯勒斯
你就是凯勒斯的人。
然后我就回去之后。
结束所有东西
我就说
那就来凯勒斯
然后
今年第九年了
明白
所以一直在这里面。
然后
开始逐渐
就是
因为结束产品
结束得多
因为中国最开始
进入户外行业
活动仅仅是一方面。
另外一方面就是
装备器械
然后随着差不多
这二十多年的
装备器械的发展
给逐渐在这行业里面。
逐渐慢慢就做起来。
对
当然还是
这个东西最主要的。
就是还是爱好
废话不多说了
我跟大家聊聊
这个
刚人波棋
好吗？
咱们从简单来聊起。
为什么大家老提
就是我都已经算是。
挺热爱户外的人了。
但其实我之前
虽然名字很熟
但我大概都不知道。
是怎么回事
我都不知道
这个刚人波棋
到底是个
能爬的雪山
还是一个什么？
徒步路线
为什么大家老提
而且我知道前些年。
不是有一个
电影
张阳导演的
就叫刚人波棋
评价也很高
其实我当时也没看。
我其实直到
2024年
还是23年
就是前几年
23年
我才大概真的知道。
刚人波棋是怎么回事。
跟那些不了解的朋友们。
分享
刚人波棋是一座山。
在中国咱们西藏的。
阿里地区的普兰县。
是钢底斯山脉的主峰。
叫刚人波棋
然后它的海拔有
6638米
当然有一些数据
是6656米
数据不太一样
但大概是一个
6000多米的雪山。
然后长得特别
有特点
就是很多雪山
就是冰激凌顶
对吧？
顶上在雪仙以下
是山
是大地色的
山石
然后雪仙以上都是雪。
但是刚人波棋的那个顶峰。
它是像阶梯状一样的。
就是一行一行的样子。
这个可能是
如果你到阿里
到普兰
你接近刚人波棋之后。
你的第一个印象
就是这个山非常容易。
被分辨出来
它长得不一样
因为这个山的底部。
是花钢眼
但是它顶部
是叫后层力眼
是不一样的一种
成绩眼
然后它成绩眼的天然是。
一层一层水瓶叠放。
就像那种千层的蛋糕一样。
然后再加上雪的外壳。
所以长得非常非常有特点。
我再往上查了一下。
地质雪上
甚至专门的名字
来形容这样的岩石结构。
叫刚人波棋地层
叫Kalash Formation。
本质上就是
因为它有不同的岩石结构。
再加上冰川的钦石。
高原这种强峰的
风化的一些雕着
最后形成了
这种非常有特点的外观。
而且刚人波棋的外观。
还有一个特点
它特别像是金字塔形。
它有四面
这四面几乎是完全对称的。
不是一个像圆追形的。
或者是一个不规则形的。
追形的山
它像这个金字塔
有四面的对称的
这么一个形状
在自然界反正非常罕见。
这可能也是后来
为什么刚人波棋
在历史上
获得了一些
非常不同地位的原因。
我今年马年
这个
当报再来一个赞语的。
康承伯奇
今天马年
康承伯奇比较受关注。
你们二位给分享分享。
为什么马年
大家会这么愿意来呢？
它是可能对于
在文化层面上会更受重视。
是吗？
我先说个通俗的
你说个通俗的
他为什么说
一定是这一个年份。
这座山这么受关注。
因为在这个漫长的。
文化发展过程中
这座山已经被人格化了。
然后它有生日
今年是它的生日
它属马的本命年
所以说大家的不一样万里。
过来之后
就是给它庆祝生日来了。
明白
所以说就很特殊
这么火
比较特殊
这是一个
我就是通俗意义上的一个讲。
如果你在马年
转山的话
你的功德乘以13。
今年转一圈
等于平时转13圈。
我今年也转了一圈。
再加上去年一圈
现在等于说
14圈的转圈
功德了
朋友们
我也算是
帮助基本无害的听友们。
我至少转的时候
我脑子里装着你们的。
对不对
我帮大家转了14圈。
把功德
分享给你们
我在
纲人波奇的时候
我跟当地的旅行社的朋友聊。
他说去年一年
应该是
大概是26万人
去过纲人波奇
这是流量
今年预计是140万人。
然后今年
我去转的时候
我也明显发现
在纲人波奇政府
为了迎接更大的客流量。
更多的游客
更多的信众
确实在
转山路线的沿线上。
基础设施
做了很多升级
什么多加了很多
那种移动式的
高级的
公共洗手间
然后加了那种
就那个小柱子
柱子上个按钮
你按能报警
你知道吗？
现在
纲人波奇转山路线上。
是有这种
高科技的现代装备的。
然后咱们再
多介绍两句纲人波奇。
就是除了你看
非常特别
它同时
确实从这个
地理意义上
它也很重要
有四条大河
都发源于
纲人波奇
或者纲人波奇附近。
而且纲人波奇转
不是说
它像金子塔
它有四面
其实这四面
各有一条河的
源头
像北边
是印度河的源头
东边是
亚洲藏不疆的源头。
然后西边
是一条河
叫象泉河的源头
然后南边
是孔雀河的源头
这些河
有些大有些小
但基本上
你可以理解为
它灌溉了整个
南亚的次大陆
养活了数十亿人
今年转山
虽然因为天气原因。
很冷
我当时非常非常艰难。
但整体的体验还是挺好的。
因为路上人不是很多。
而且
大部分都是咱们藏族同胞。
你在路上走的时候。
这些人
给你带来的精神面望的。
这种感受
是完全不一样的
我是很感激
非常庆幸
我能在25号之前。
在游客很少的时候。
走完这一圈
然后跟大家分享一下。
为什么值得去
首先咱们说值不值得去。
我先给答案
我旗帜先饼子觉得。
非常值得去
如果你的身体条件允许。
没有到那种非常危险的。
在高海拔
会遇到的那种高山病。
就是所谓的高反
这种情况的话
我觉得
哪怕不是马年
我觉得你早晚
安排去一次
有几个原因
咱们就是从浅到深属。
第一西藏就很值得去。
很多朋友
现在当然
旅游也来发展了
终于来得方便了
大家生活条件也好了。
很多朋友可能都去过西藏。
我第一次去西藏是2010年。
我大一暑假
就在那个时候
反正去西藏还没那么容易。
当时清藏铁路
刚刚修好没几年
就哪怕做着这种
经历无数人力物力。
伟大的基建
建好的清藏铁路
你要进藏
可能你当时
我记得做英作
还要做40多个小时。
跟现在相比
也是要麻烦很多
当时自驾
也没有现在这么流行。
放到现在
真的进藏
已经是有各种各样的方式。
自驾
火车
飞机
容易很多了
所以说
没有去过西藏的朋友。
首先西藏
就真的很值得一去。
为啥去戈尔伯齐
首先戈尔伯齐在西藏。
其次你要从西藏去阿里。
阿里是西藏的
西部地区的
这么一个地方
之前早年间
阿里还叫无人区
因为阿里他太偏了。
海拔又高
又偏
然后大部分的地方。
是隔壁一般的地貌。
就是他其实不是特别的一局。
他广貿而荒武
当年阿里
很多地方是无人区的。
当然仍然
感谢咱们的基建
现在做得非常非常好。
去年是第一次去阿里。
今年第二次
我10年去西藏的时候。
感觉阿里还是很难去的地方。
坐车也都很麻烦
现在你去
公路说的太好
然后虽然有时候一开。
你要连着开一天
你都不知道那路怎么那么长。
地方怎么那么大
但是也不显得危险。
对吧？
因为中间开着开着。
有夹药站
有城镇
有连锁的快捷酒店。
有医院
什么都有
所以说现在大家是能够。
以一个比较可控的。
比较方便的方式去到阿里的。
阿里曾被人称为这种。
最西藏的西藏
就是最能代表西藏气质的藏区。
你去临织
临织其实是
属于是藏地里面
植被比较丰富的
风景比较秀美的
所谓藏地小江南
很多人说
但是它不是
最具有西藏气质的藏区。
但阿里就是最有这种。
倾藏高原藏地气质的藏区。
然后最后
刚人波奇在阿里的普兰县。
普兰县又有很多风景名胜。
我觉得就是风景名胜。
你除了看刚人波奇之外。
旁边好多各种各样的美景。
比如说刚人波奇山脚下不远。
就是圣湖叫马庞庸措。
非常美
然后马庞庸措的那一端。
就是纳木纳尼那个雪山。
纳木纳尼雪山太美了。
所以说你看
你如果去刚人波奇。
为什么要去
就是你除了
见识藏地文化
阿里的独特的风貌之外。
还能赚刚人波奇
如果你说你体力不行。
或者天气不好
没赚成之后
你附近还能马庞庸措。
纳木纳尼拉昂措
拉昂措就是被称为鬼湖。
马庞庸措是圣湖
你还可以去游览一下这种美景。
然后你像我这两年去。
刚人波奇也都是自驾去的。
今年是自驾去
但是后面因为有事情。
我是从普兰县的机场。
阿里的机场
直接坐飞机走了
但去年我是直接开过去开会来。
路过刚人波奇的这个219国道。
有一条路线
是被咱们这种
经常自驾的旅行者们。
成为阿里大环线
阿里大环线讲而言之。
拉萨出发
沿着318国道转219。
然后经过日卡泽
到达施权河镇
施权河镇出发之后。
再折回317国道。
然后经过阿里的东部的。
枪堂草原
再往纳曲方向
最后返回拉萨
拉萨到日卡泽
到阿里
到纳曲到拉萨
这么一个环线
所以说为什么要去刚人波奇。
这算是第一个理由。
就是你去刚人波奇。
你是能收获非常多。
非常丰富的
不一样的
不可替代的
极其有价值的旅行体验。
反正我记得我
第一次去西藏的时候。
我坐青藏铁路的高铁。
就路上我就感觉
一直盯着窗外
就首先太美了
首先太美了
我甚至都没有觉得会疲惫。
因为40多个小时。
你进藏之后
那个风景其实
也有重复度的
但是我还是就舍不得不看。
就一直往窗外看
那个铁道旁边
一直会有铁路的保护员。
值班的那些同志们。
他们见火蛇过去
他们就会在铁路旁边。
然后跟你敬礼
当时我还是个大学生。
19岁
我自己觉得还是挺震撼的。
也很感动
然后我第一次转山。
是在那一年的年底。
大概是10月份快结束的时候。
然后我才进行了
自己的第一次转山。
那个时候我已经在这住了。
大概是3个多月的时间了。
整个身体状况
高反其实是已经完全适应掉了。
很大适应
已经适应得非常好了。
然后我要去走
就走当时就用了两天的时间。
把这个山就转完了。
转完
当时印象最深的就是。
风沙特别大
因为10月中旬
然后风特别大
沙也特别大
那时候还没有雪
就是风大沙大
然后大到什么程度呢？
就是大概我面前
三四米远的地方
我就完全看不见
然后又是下山的时候。
是顶头风
就是几乎就是顶着狂风。
然后往前走
那个时候我记得挺惨的。
路过了几个土豚
几个大土豚
然后当时我就把自己的身子。
缩在土豚底下
根本就走不了了
走不了了就躺在那里。
然后看见很多
我后边的小伙伴
慢慢地超过我
也还有很多人过来问我。
说你怎么了
但当时我也不知道我怎么了。
只是觉得走不了了。
然后再走了一会
我就躺在那里觉得。
哎呀 要不不走了。
就要不就这么着急。
就到了这种程度
然后但是呢？
就是休息这会
又缓过来了嘛？
缓过来了
又往前走
又往下走
我就走到上海下的时候。
去了一个东部交代馆。
睡觉子
然后老板说
你怎么回事
行程都说土
你去哪里了
我说我就转山了
他说你是我
见过什么最惨的一个。
最狼狈的一个人
最惨的一个
转山的人
你这
你跟
应该路上
应该有很多
兄弟
太多了
人家跟你说话
你也能听明白
我自己出来的经历就是。
我经常会跟对方
两个人都能感觉出来。
两方
彼此都很友好
都带着笑容
带着说啥都听不懂。
对
就是他是多文化
不同人之间善意的。
甚至可能这个善意。
是盲目的交换
对
其实挺有意思
反正就是巨大的善意。
我就完全就丢给你。
你接不接得住
是你的事情
反正是我要拿出来的。
是
我顺便问个问题
因为咱们这个
这次这个直播
也是咱们中国山逆色。
凯德是这个活动的一部分。
这个山逆色
说到这儿
我觉得这个问题
其实就互之欲出
就钢神波棋
这个山
或者这个路线
对于你们诸位
他有颜色吗？
如果非要让你选一个颜色。
他可能是什么颜色。
大方要不你先说
白色
对
为什么？
神圣
就是天黑了
就是走路的时候
天
就是磨磨糊糊的时候。
它是一条白色路线。
然后就是你
啊？
就是在黑夜之中
你看到一条白色的线。
对对对
我们平时
一个是这个白色的线。
对对对
已经不是有一个
人很多走过的
一条路吗？
对对对
那我觉得这个路
本身的背后就是
就是无数个
一代一代人
因为本来就没有路嘛？
就是大家
因为对某种文化
这个不管是敬畏
一个信仰也好
大家就是在那
这个白色是走
是那些人的
这个
那些尊重和心灵
给他走出来了
给他具体的呈现出来。
所以我觉得这个颜色。
也挺有意思
因为我本来以为
这个白色忽可能是雪山。
可能是那些颜色
但我们想到你说的是。
重重
是黑暗中前人
走过的那个路的指引。
对
实话挺好
黑暗中前人走过
那的确是
的确是
因为去年我
因为要一天走
但是我出发又晚了。
我最后的后半段
我最后
从不通地丁
我没走 没走多久。
就天就黑了
我后面只有十几公里。
都是黑天赶路
然后我能get到。
当旺说那个感觉
因为当时你说
这山里也没有路灯。
没有啥的
其实就是月光下
那个有的
前人走的那痕迹
然后偶尔时不时
能碰到深夜
我也不知道为啥
有一些藏族的同胞兄弟。
人家还在
晚上也在那
就是继续跟我一样拔射。
这印象挺深的
当旺是白色
二位呢？
泳哥
我
有两个颜色
你说
一个是绿色
一个是蓝色
为什么会有两个颜色呢？
就是一个是
你来到这天空的蓝色。
还有一个就是
你来到这个地方
你真的沿途路过了。
很多的圣湖
他们的湖就是绿色。
和蓝色
就在冬天
那个时候
就是我们看到
冬天那个蓝
真的是
就是我
所以我就很有感触。
包括我们之前
我们有山地色
下落的蔓延蓝
就是你没有到那个环境下。
你没看到那个蓝
触发不了你这个东西。
对
所以我们在
我们来的路上
跟我们同车的小伙伴。
我把车停在了那个湖边。
就那个错边
他们下去之后都
哇 这太美了
这个蓝色和这个绿色。
能融合得这么好
是
他们的感觉真的是。
完全不一样
就他们自己
到了这个地方之后。
他们才感觉
这个景色是很好
而且现在我们
包括现在从
阿里地区这几个
知名的地点
什么高尔伯奇
纳姆奈尼
和马鹏勇厨
真的
就是你一旦看到
这些东西的时候
我上一次在来的时候。
也是风特别大的一个天气。
开车到那个
马鹏勇厨的那个湖那儿。
停到那儿了之后
然后当地的人就跟我讲。
说你可以来这儿
去徒步一下
我当时的想法
我说必须来
然后其实我这次来的时候。
我们那个
我都装了一台自行车。
对 本来是想
自行车骑一下的
但是因为我们人多。
没地方放车了
没地方
我说最后没办法
我说我就是
我说那没办法
我说那我就明年
没办法
勇哥又使出老结魂。
推着车来
因为刚看到他的时候。
你的感觉就是
我怎么能亲近他
然后在昨天
我们来的路上
就是夕阳快
前天快夕阳
还没有夕阳的时候。
纳姆奈尼
各种各样的湖
然后也
然后毛牛
羊裙
然后再加上
黑井河
背着我们的
一路开
那个感觉真的
就是我们小伙伴
当时就是拍了那个视频。
就是他跟我讲说
这个地方太美了
很美
就是真的就是
你来到这个地方
你看到的这些东西。
是不一样的
狼和绿
对
反而不是一座山
而这座山周边
所有的一切
呈现出的那个样子。
对 就是他
你所有的一切
你都得接受他
你都得包容他
你都得能够站在这。
他给你多大的风
你也应该接受他
因为这是对他来说。
这是一个很正常的事情。
而且从我说的角度讲。
你在一个合适的位置。
站在湖边
在他说的雪山 天空。
还是湖泊的蓝水
都当用在那个
蓝色绿色的湖室里面。
全部看得见
对
我们就你停下喝咖啡。
那个地方不是
下面不有一个站道吗？
我就停下去
那马就在那个
河边喝水
对
然后背后就是雪山。
哎呀 太美了
就我们喝咖啡那个地方。
沿出来的
对 昨天我们在路上。
在某个厕所旁边停了一圈。
是这个地方
对
是
秦哥 你的颜色是什么？
我可能就呼之欲出了。
因为我已经穿在身上了。
对 我
橙色
对 这个地方
我猜到了
对
你猜到了
我在这个地方
最大的概括就是
我就肥红色
不是橙色是肥红色。
肥红色
对
是我们这个地方
夕阳的颜色
也可能待会就看见了。
对
因为来的
我是从拉萨过来
用了三天多的时间。
我第一次来
然后这条路
又跑过无数次
其实在这条路上
蓝天也好
白云也好
雪山 湖泊
都会看到很多
但是我永远忘不了。
我第一次来的时候。
就那个下午
那个下午
蓝色完了之后
我其实看了一路的蓝色了。
反而是到了这个地方之后。
就突然间傍晚的时候。
整个天空
天地全是肥红色
无论是雪山 天空 云 材材。
还是我们面前的这个草原。
全都是肥红色的
然后
我当时觉得
这个地方可能
而且那个肥红色
持续的时间很多
大概不到一分钟的时间。
就天黑了
就蓝掉10克了
对吧？
然后我就觉得
那一刻
那一瞬间就是最美的。
而且在往后
我无数次去制作山。
徒步的时候
我往往出来的时候。
基本上都是快黄昏的时候。
我在那个山
那个很远的一个小口。
看到远处的那个
那个叫什么山口嘛？
对吧？
那个山口可以看到草原。
可以看到那个蓝色的湖泊。
但是只要
那个山口呈现出
一片肥红和金色
我就知道我快到了。
差不多就是我要抵达。
这一片也是正面的一个山口。
又浪漫了
所以说
大家如果来我们咖啡馆的时候。
你就看到我们咖啡馆很多。
就类似于我穿的这个颜色中。
肥红色的那种包
还有我们的LOGO招牌。
全是肥红色
就是这个原因
加的颜色
安全抵达之后的颜色。
对于你来说
我心里想的是灰色。
灰色好像很特别
土黄色
就是
这是我对高人波提。
真的是最大的感受。
为啥
我觉得是灰色
或者土黄色
就是
我觉得这个印象
之前被人
给
浪漫化了太多了
太浪漫化了
就是大家一提到高人波奇。
就是觉得这个地方。
很神圣
很向往
我觉得反而有时候。
会给人带来一些
不切实际的印象
比如说有些朋友
我才去过一些
那种风景
特别秀丽的地方
比如说新西兰
我举个例子
就像童话一样
童话里面小到
就是青山绿水
有时候当你看了
很多这种浪漫化的描述之后。
你说
好神圣
好美丽
但你其实来了之后。
不是的
就像刚才醒哥说的。
它是风很大
沙图很多
它很真实
我第一次
这台是可能户外
最真实的样子
很多朋友
怀着一个就是比较虚妄的。
对于户外的想象
来了之后
说不定
他会觉得
这怎么跟我
听的那些
对 那些剪辑过的。
加了绿镜之后的那些视频。
跟照片里承认的不一样。
但这其实
这就是最现实的
咱们户外的样子
当时我第一次来的时候。
我说
没想到原来这个路线。
还是直背挺少的
没有直背
沙图挺多的
但是这个灰色
你走着走着
我这个灰色不是个点。
是你走着走着发现。
这个灰色背后
它的那个气质
是一种非常能
打动人心的气质
就是你就好像
那个灰色在哪儿了。
在那个地上
在每一个刻长头的。
咱们这些
在那个衣服上
那些衣服
我还要在它的衣服上。
你也很狼狈
就这些灰色
在每个人身上
它虽然看起来很灰。
很狼狈
但是这个灰色的底色。
可能大家
不管是对于
某些文化的向往
还是对于户外的憧憬。
我觉得本质来讲
这个灰色
反而可能是
最符合真实的
户外气质的颜色
而不是那种
被过度浪漫化的
什么？
特别艳的
童话版的颜色
对吧？
所以说我
这也是我对
刚儿摩天的一个印象。
就是如果有天
你能来到这
你会发现打动你
可能不是
绝对的美景
景是美的
你会摇阔
那些点缀在
遗忘无遗的
这种隔壁平衡的
那些糊跟错
当然是美的
但是你一定会献到很多。
你可能在
绝对一场
不算美的东西
但是那些东西
在每个人的
精神世界
呈现一下
他又很打动人
比如说
走在那个路上
就是灰色的土地
但是那些身上
沾着灰色的土的
藏土大姐大妈
他就会有好的
过来问我
说你饿不饿
可不可
这些东西
所以我觉得
这种灰色
本质是
这些上阳朴实的第四。
然后第三个原因
我这可能是
有点像我
硬家的一个原因
但是真的是我的
亲身体会
就是高反
除非有小部分朋友。
咱们内陆的朋友
要不然就是基因原因。
要不然就是体制原因。
可能真的是不高反。
去这个高原
4000米以上
可能会非常的适宜。
大部分的朋友
我估计
或多或少
或长或短
会经历这种
高反身体不适的症状。
很多人
慢慢适应
有些人可能会适应的慢。
有些人可能适应的快。
像以我有时候
甚至全程
我都不一定完全适应。
当然
它在不严重影响
你的身体
健康的情况下
我其实觉得这种状态。
你偶尔感受一下
它是很宝贵的
我觉得高反
是能够
最好磨你摔老的方式。
当你高反
几天之后
如果你慢慢适应过来之后。
你有多么的感恩
你有多么的游中的开心。
有一天你醒了之后。
你突然犯期间不头疼了。
今天能走了
能动了
你心里太开心了
就是对于生命的感恩。
这个可能是一个非常偏的点。
但是我真的建议诸位。
如果你有一天
到了这种高原
你有了明显的高原反应。
你就把它当做摔老体验卡。
这样的话
等你恢复过来之后。
我觉得你能更感激。
你现在健康的启破。
年轻的身体
高反对于很多人来说。
也是一个很宝贵的感受。
特别的体验
真的
首先你要保证自己的身体。
健康安全的时候
但是我是觉得
如果你要在适应海拔的过程中。
你的身体里有一些不适。
这个不适
其实是一个非常好的机会。
你能够了解自己的身体。
健康有多么宝贵
或是自如行动的时候。
有多么宝贵
我自己
这个要稍稍稍稍本意的。
但是我真实的感受。
我觉得有时候
你在适应海拔的时候。
有一些不适的阶段。
特别像你提前体验了摔老。
就是走路也走不快。
也会喘
像他还要刚刚还跑一会儿。
对
很多人来说高反
其实是一个无成本。
咱们说高反
咱们就说适应海拔的过程。
它其实某种程度上。
是一个你可以提前去感受摔老。
感受一个健康的体魄。
是那么重要的一个小过程。
然后后面的几个推荐理由。
就是我想说
朋友们
你来这儿之后
首先你不要非常
因为网上那些发的帖子。
对风光有多么大的。
滤镜的预期
但是我想说的是
不管你对风光有没有预期。
这一轮的体验
一定不会让你觉得失望。
这个体验
包括刚才提到的那种人。
人跟人之间的体验。
还有就是你极度疲惫之后的。
可能对于跟自己对话。
对于自己那种新的认识。
我觉得刚才
醒哥跟弹望说走完之后很空。
我去年走那次肯定也是。
但是因为也很累
我后来走到最后
累到已经不行了
但是这种跟做对话的过程。
走到最后你说
我已经没有空
再去生出一些感慨。
然后再生出一些
对于这些风光的一些形容。
跟开探
这个感觉也是挺珍贵。
对 我们自己开玩笑说。
这条路难道什么程度呢？
一开始我们走是靠兴趣。
好玩
走着走着你就发现不对了。
有点累
然后我就有点靠着。
有点疲惫
然后我再走一会
我就发现有点不对了。
我太深入了
我有点求生本能上来。
我必须要走出去
然后我又走了一会。
就不是求生本能了。
我要凭意志力走完。
然后到了最后
连意志力都没有了。
你就在那里在天地之间。
麻木地拖着你这句肉体。
往前行走
那个时候其实就抵达了。
你这个深情合一的状态了。
对 它这几个阶段。
总觉得挺有意思的。
挺准确的
泳哥 你要给大家激发向往。
你会怎么激发
不用激发
你只要出来
就可以感受
先上路 先出发
对 就是我妈跟我说的那句话。
特别有意思
就是家再好你都不喜欢。
但是我说我每次出来。
我都会想家
其实一个道理
就是不用去感受任何东西。
就是你先出来
然后再一步一步去感受。
感受自然给你的东西。
感受其他生物给你的东西。
感受其他朋友给你的东西。
你只要出来
我认为什么都可以解决。
好 这就是大概
我觉得就是
为什么值得去
刚人波棋逛一逛的原因。
然后这个转山
你到了塔尔金小镇之后。
你这个在小镇上
小镇上相对来说
还是比较物资丰富的。
它肯定比不了
咱们内陆城市那么发达。
有这种五星级酒店 高级餐厅。
但是相对来说
已经比前些年
只是一个落脚点
要现在好多了
有修了非常多
这种现代的旅馆
是有那种迷散式供养的。
就是你去高原
很多朋友知道
就是你那个
什么叫迷散式供养。
你住到酒店房间里面。
酒店里面是有那种治养机。
它晚上打开之后
它是能够往房间里喷氧气的。
能让氧含量稍微高一点。
能让你的高反稍微轻一点。
你到阿里之后
毕竟当年
几年前还是偏乌人区一样的。
比较难以到达的
接近性很差的地方。
现在发生这样
已经非常烧高香了。
但是大家还是不要抱太高的。
迟速方面的期望
标准不要抬得太高。
然后你到塔尔金小镇之后。
你就可以开始转山。
小镇不大
基本上就在任何一个地方。
你都几乎可以在20分钟内。
步行到转山的起点。
它有一个像景区入口的一个地方。
你就到这个
咱们汉族的朋友
转山里边是要买票的。
就是像去观光一样。
咱们观光客
但是藏族的信众朋友。
他们是可以自由出入。
然后这个转山
分为外转跟内转
咱们一般说的转山就是外转。
就是围着山绕一个大圈。
大概是52公里
这52公里平均海拔。
都在4700米以上。
因为起点就在4700米以上。
甚至好像有一半路程。
平均海拔可能在5000米以上。
我之前看的数据
我不知道有没有一半。
但是确实中间
你翻越中马拉雅口的时候。
前后加起来
至少在120公里。
都在4800以上。
翻雅口最高到5600多。
5660米还是5680米。
这一圈52公里
大部分人
是两到三天走完的。
如果是两天走完的话。
基本上都会夜宿
叫止热寺
这一圈
转山其实特别像
欧洲的很多徒步的路线。
就是你路上
会有人类痕迹
人类文明
它有这种小木屋
有补给站
有这种所谓的Logging。
你像国内有很多
其实哪怕海拔再低一点的。
再没有这么人际
罕致一点的徒步路线。
其实路上是没有什么？
这种小木屋了
没有补给的
你得重装
你得背着帐篷
或者你得倾向倒
就像当年我去什么南极路。
咱们什么新疆的一些线。
西藏的一些线
甚至云南的一些线。
它看起来没有
刚人波棋
海拔高那么艰难
但反而它其实全靠你自己。
因为你这个路线
就完全在山林里
在山野里
除了起点是可能是个村庄。
你后面几天全靠自己。
但刚人波棋
它好就好在
这一圈
因为可能是之前
信众转山
传统太过于
根深蒂固
所以说其实沿路
发展出了一些补给点。
当然现在
它把它当做一个景区运营了。
其实有更多现代化的设施了。
没有那么现代化
但是多一点点
不要想的
没有脉靠长了
但是
它竟然是有几个补给点。
我现在大概算了算。
光在翻越
转往了埃口之前
这大概一半的路程里面。
就得有五六个补给点。
基本上
每隔不到10公里。
甚至这个三五公里。
可能就会有一个
就理解为有人类痕迹。
有屋子
你进去之后
有热水
有甜茶
有酥油茶
有卖水的
有卖方便面的
有卖脏面的
甚至还能住宿
但是这个住宿条件。
没有那么好就是了。
对吧？
所以说
这个补给点
其中有一个补给点。
很有名叫止热寺
这个地方本来就是。
刚人波棋
转山路线了一个寺庙。
大家这个止热寺的寺庙下。
就发现出了一片人类的聚落。
有很多小旅馆
小茶馆
我现在已经进入到这个。
转山使用建议
刚获攻略分享
两天的
转山的朋友
基本上都会夜宿止热寺。
有些人想要
再往前走一走
他就会走到这个
下一站
叫天藏台
天藏台也是一个补给点。
如果你要住止热寺的话。
相当于你走了
大概20公里左右。
也就是说你
第一天走了20公里。
第二天
可能要走30公里。
所以说这个就称之为先天后苦。
一般这个咱们主流的两天。
转山路线就是先天后苦。
就是在这条
52公里的徒步路线上。
有一个牙口需要翻。
牙口大家知道
就相当于两个山峰中间的安部。
两个山峰中间
那个矮的地方
奥运的地方
叫牙口
就是很多时候
你要翻过这个山
你肯定不会没事扰事。
故意要翻山顶
你就翻这个安部
这个就叫牙口
但中马来牙口
其实海拔不及的
你想5600多米。
我爬过的
很多5000多米的入门机雪山。
都没这么高
四姑娘山大峰
5，0几十米
对吧？
四姑娘大二三峰
好像都没有中马来牙口高。
这是海拔
然后纳马峰有没有。
纳马峰可能比较高一点。
纳马峰是不是5，800。
这个徒步路线
其实强度不低的
这个也是我要说的。
就是很多朋友
他们可能爬过一些入门机雪山。
或者有些高海拔经验。
他会觉得那走一个徒步路线。
这不是很轻松吗？
但不是了
就是我这你想想
今年还算是爬了木石塔阁。
7000多米多米的人。
今年我去走这个
高人波棋
我该高反照样高反。
因为首先这个地方。
毕竟第一
它路程长
它对体能消耗比较大。
第二
它天气仍然也是很多变。
第三
阿里地区直背非常稀熟。
它不像川西或者云南。
有些地方高海拔
这个山是
到顶的时候5000多米高。
但是它底下
它是有直背的
整体那个海洋量是比较高的。
但阿里区整体海洋量非常低。
几乎就没有直背
所以在高人波棋
高反很合理
很容易
你很容易这样就能高反。
所以说两天的路线。
具体的几个补给点。
大家可以去往上查一查。
对
刚才就是说
住在植鹅寺
先天后苦
但是我有些人想
先苦后甜的话
第一天把整把拉压扣翻完。
翻完之后的第一个补给点。
叫不动地丁
这名字听了
都像梳理写的一样。
不动地丁
大地的地丁字丁
再往前
还有一两个
我不知道名字
我就理解为
不动地丁
没理解公里
这些地方都可以住。
我自己是因为
一些独特的原因
也不是为了硬装
我这两年都是一天走完了。
52公里
去年走了也不少
走了在17个小时。
其实人家走得快的。
15个小时
12个小时
甚至去年好像办了一个。
高人波棋
类似于
有点像个月月跑比赛。
但是他不是
一个商业化的比赛。
类似于登山大会
我上网记得
看过那个信息
第一名
六个多小时就走了。
六个多小时跑完了。
把平均海拔4700米以上的。
一个52公里的步道。
他也跑完了
这东西真没法比
我自己这两年
去年是17个小时走完。
当时是故意的
因为要爬木尔塔格。
然后当时朋友说
一天之内
把高人波棋走完
有助于
锻炼自己的这种
高海拔
长距离
疲惫状态下
行尽的这种能力
所以去年是一天走完。
今年也是一天走完了。
其实今年我本来
特别想走个两天
甚至三天
我想好好享受一下。
我知道现在都非常建议大家。
不要一天走完
除非你有特别的拉链目的。
否则的话
真的一天走
哪怕你体能再好
它也是一个匆匆赶路的状态。
它没办法很好的去享受。
路上的风景跟人文。
我今年是因为我后面有工作。
我要赶飞机
所以说我今年也是一天走。
今天走的更久
理论上我今年
其实体能是进步了的。
但是我走了19个小时。
但这个是因为装备没带够。
太崩溃
我现在装备没带够。
当时低温和大风
让我体能的消耗
然后质量的消耗
还有高反的加重
都对我非常严重的影响。
这个我很惭愧了
如果大家要是
你真的是想打算一日走完的话。
如果你不高反
很有可能大部分人走的。
应该比我快
当然我更建议大家。
就是至少分两天走。
我这两年一天走完。
都有好几个小时在晚上。
早上你出发早的
天还没亮
你早点出发
等于说是晚上
这还好
因为很多人都是天不亮出发。
路上有头灯
一堆人
别有一番风味
但是藏族的朋友
他们晚上基本上是不走路的。
对 人家不着急
就是晚上天一黑
他又找地方住了
这路上住的地方
其实也都很简陋
我跟大家形容一下。
那些补给点
就是你住的是什么样子。
就是大部分是大通铺。
就是你可以列为多人间。
一个房间里面
有多少床
你就合一而眠
他也有被子有啥
但东西他也不会天天换。
他也不是旅馆
那被子可能说
大家都一块盖
你要是就对卫生有要求。
可能你就不太能接受。
你像在止热寺
就我说大部分人
第一天会住的那个地方。
他可能那个止热寺这一站。
住宿比较发达
有一些相对先进一点的。
稍微都不能说高档了。
稍微正常的旅馆
里面可能是有什么标签。
大床房
就是你可以一个人住。
或者两个人住的
其他那个补给点
一部分都是合一而眠的那种。
大通铺
或者是就是茶馆
他那个茶馆都是像那个。
就是白天是饭店茶馆。
桌子两边是那种长椅。
像bench
就是一个桌子的两边是两张bench。
晚上呢？
这个bench
这个椅子上就能睡人。
你能理解吗？
他不是那个凳子
他是个长椅
你就睡在长椅上
这也是会睡人的地方。
就是这样的住宿环境。
但是我个人是觉得很好。
我个人觉得那个气氛很好。
当然我没有经历过。
最后25号开山之后。
人多的时候
我想象了一下
如果人很多的话非常拥挤。
然后资源
几对
可能是不是住宿田也一般。
但是我前几天
就是4月19号走的时候。
因为人可能没有那么多。
我买到一个茶馆
我真的都很不想走。
气氛真挺好
就是那个茶馆里面。
有人在那休息
有人在那聊天
有人在那喝茶
大家就是不仅不慢。
而且很暖
外面很冷
我真的不想出门
我是不觉得那个条件差。
我非常想待着
而且人也很友好
就从那个转山的人。
到那个老板
整个人都很友好
有时候你要走的时候。
有可能
你会遇到那种老板。
感觉对你来说
没有那么热情
是因为他们不懂不同话。
他跟你不好交流
我这次前两天走的时候。
就是我在一个茶馆里。
最后我都吃完快要走了。
然后我看到近来
两个汉族的算是这个游客。
姐姐穿上冲锋衣
感觉得有40多岁。
然后坐在那跟那个藏族的老板。
那个老板
其实也就是个小姑娘。
二三十岁的一个女老板。
就打招呼
然后女老板好像就没有来得及。
及时招呼他们
那有个姐姐就怎么说呢？
就是不太开心
慢慢来来就走了
我当时其实觉得
你才没必要慢慢来来。
我说人家这个
他没听懂
他也不是不招呼你。
我也没
那我也没必要飞在这。
我说这么多店
我没必要飞在这吃。
我心想是
我说
但是你这个心态
没必要
咱们如果要是
到时候去
这个转山的话
还是对于藏族的朋友。
也是多一些理解跟包容。
毕竟咱们这个语言有时候不一样。
他们很多当地的藏民。
也不像是
现在年轻的藏族朋友。
学了汉语
然后跟咱们这个
家之关
然后生活方式都越来越去童了。
但那些你像当地的藏民。
很多时候
他跟咱们还是会有很多。
沟通上的这些障碍的。
这个就是我对于这个外转。
转山的一些
实用性的建议
我在路上的时候
我是想一天走完
我走得很快
我会收获两种评价。
一种是年轻的那些藏民。
他们好几个人会招呼我。
因为当我走中马拉雅口的时候。
可能他们觉得这个点。
到中马拉雅口还要翻。
一定是当天走的
因为如果是住在直车寺。
第二天一早翻中马拉雅口。
应该是早上
七八点 八九点就开始翻雅口。
我当时中午翻的时候。
他们觉得你应该是今天走。
好多藏民年轻的就来问我。
说你是一天走完的。
今天出发的
我说对
然后他们就很爱打听。
说你几天走
他们就来算
后来他们说你走挺快的。
因为其实当时
我到中马拉雅口的时候。
走得其实还是挺快的。
后来是到雅口上天气突变。
风刮得很大
然后我才速度明显减半。
状态受了严重影响。
这是一种评价
就是他们说
哥们你这不简单
挺快的
我记得我在直车寺。
还是在天藏台
中间补给的时候
有个藏族哥们
感觉比我年轻二十多岁。
他还说
他说你几点出发了。
我说五点半
他说你比我快
他说五点出发了
他说他到底还比我晚。
一种是这样的评价。
卡我走得快
对不对
当我走得快的时候。
想要一天走完的时候。
一种评价是
就是说你们厉害
还有一种评价
就是一些中年的
老年的大哥
他们会非常善意地跟我说。
说不着急
他说慢慢走
我相信他们不是说。
想我不行
他们也不是说自己不行。
他们就是觉得
这个路线你得慢慢走。
他们能走快
但他们没觉得没必要。
他也不自己不走快。
但还有一部分原因。
他们可能整个的藏族同胞的。
他们的生活气质
生活方式就是这样。
他不着急
你像他们那天黑的晚。
八九点才天黑
我六七点翻过牙口。
到不动地钉的那几个。
不计单的时候
大家都不动了
他们明明能走
他们一定要想
当天走完
一定是能走完
我是当天走完了
我就走到凌晨
但是他们不走
就在那待着了
就是吃吃喝喝
就睡了
也不着急
我自己是非常羡慕。
而且非常推崇这种方式。
后来我记得
我到最后有尊重普思。
那个补给点和尊重普思。
前面的补给点的时候。
算是茶馆吧？
老板都很友好
跟我聊天
说你还要走
天都黑了
我说今天走完
他说别走了
他说天都黑了
他说天黑这就别走了。
就劝我
我当时真的很动摇。
很不想走
包括尊重普思的时候。
我在补给点
有个哥们
就是老板
他说我见过你
他说我去年见过
后来我俩反正在那儿调了一下。
我发现他真的去年见过。
我说你在哪见的
他说在翻牙口的时候。
我当时有一瞬间
他就觉得很感动
他说这个话的时候。
也不是要套进我
他就是在陈述一个事实。
他说我记得你
我当时真的有一种。
就是很感动的
奇怪的感觉
就是他还记得我
可能也是因为
我不知道有特点
走得快还是怎么着。
他当时跟我说
你别走
他说后面这几公里有狼。
我其实很害怕
今年我尤其害怕
因为今年冬天没过去。
天还很冷
天冷的时候狼饿
你知道吗？
就是天气暖
或者是小动物多
狼没那么多
他说有狼你别走
有狼有熊的
我当时挣扎了很久。
我很害怕
而且当时
今年我走的时候
我发现板上
路上的人明显比较少。
因为确实次月
还是比较早的
这个人流量就是小。
但我最后还是走完了。
我并不是拖大
我当时很紧张
我也是没办法
但是总而言之
我非常不建议大家。
除非你真的是
拉脸为目的
或者你走得很快
你不会走到大半夜。
你说你特地为了一天走完。
我觉得我尊重
否则的话
建议大家不要学我。
走到大半夜
一个是很疲惫
一个是少看了很多风景。
一个真的
尤其是尊重普思
到中堆的
七公里
六公里
其实挺危险
尤其是大半夜走
那一段是最容易遇到狼跟熊。
我去年的时候走钢人过棋。
去年走得更晚
因为出发的晚
走到凌晨三四点
我路上见了两次狼。
然后后来到镇上之后。
我就跟当地人聊
我说那是不是狼
他说对
他说那就是有狼
他说那个
但是夏天还好
他说你不用担心
去年我六月份走
算是夏天
他说夏天还好
狼一般不会攻击人。
冬天的话狼饿
他说甚至会跑到镇上。
他说你在冬天的话。
你在镇上都能看到狼。
因为在山里他找到东西吃了。
我今年给我下坏了。
当时其中一个补给点的。
一个藏族女生
就是老板的女儿
还跟我说
他说安慰我
他说没事
他说会碰到狼
但是他说我们碰到狼都很开心。
他那个普通话
不是特别好
他意思就是说
如果他们能碰到狼的话。
可能算是个幸运的事。
就是他不是那么容易见到狼。
他说见到狼的话
他们很开心
因为他们知道狼
也不会吃人
我说不会吗？
他说不会
我说能吃什么？
他们就吃什么兔子。
什么羊
他的意思就是不会吃。
然后就补离具
他说但是好像是
不吃藏族人
会吃汉族人
我说你别吓我
你们有没有那种
就是户外经历里
目睹过的
或者自己经历过的。
我先分享一个
可以
因为也是去年刚发生的。
就是因为没有做好准备。
其实那天我
就是这座山
我上山的时候
我其实很有自信的。
我大概去过很多次了。
我要拿到装备
我要拿到补给
然后我大概
需要用到时长
包括当年的天气
我都心里有数
然后我当时就另一包。
我就直接就冲了
直接就上了
关键就是上的过程中。
我捡到了一个朋友。
捡到了一个人
他当时状态不是特别好。
但是当时我就劝他。
要是说你吓去
我就赶紧别上了
他还挺坚持
就是一定要走
一定要走
然后我就问
他的一个实际情况。
他就给我讲他
大概是什么样的
一个运动经历
也很厉害的
什么样的运动经历。
然后说过多少讲
我当时大概技术判断了一下。
就这种身体素质
是没有任何问题的。
然后我们就继续往前走。
已经就过了折返点了。
我们当时是一天走完了。
对吧？
已经过了折返点了。
就没办法再回去了。
关键就是
一过了折返点的时候。
天气突然就变化了。
就无云
就从四周开始
向我们拢过来
拢过来之后
当时我第一判了
可能要下血或下冰雹。
关键是当时
我身上的衣服
是刚刚够我一个人用的。
因为他当时是要叫速穿。
然后插得又很清凉。
过去之后
他的衣服就明显就不够了。
当时温度是
每一分钟都在一句下降。
降得非常的快
然后他本来就有点不舒服。
然后降到这么快之后。
直接就高返了
当时就有点
冰零失去意识的那种感觉。
失纹了
对
当时我的第一判就是。
我只有一套衣服
往上拖了之后
把我的什么羽绒服。
把我的绷壳
把他全部给他包起来。
然后就拖着他
就往前走
没走几步
就开始下冰雹
然后当时我肉眼可见。
就地上那个白色的冰雹。
应该是在几分钟之内。
就大概激起了五公分后。
就我目之所及
然后全部都是白色的。
然后关键这个时候。
突然天就开始打雷。
关键我就
我就感觉当时那个雷。
就全部都劈在我周围。
在云里面吗？
对在云里面
然后当时卡拉是在山下。
他就大概知道我的方向。
因为我每次上山的时候。
都会告诉他我
今天的一个计划是怎么样的。
我大概会在哪里
什么时候下来
他就大概往我那个方向看的时候。
就会发现
所有的雷都劈到了。
我所在那个山上去。
然后当时他在山上。
还挺让人感动的
他就立刻就是
把自己的装备打好包。
然后到了镇上
叫了几个朋友
然后就准备上山去接应。
那个时候我还是在那个。
又是雷
又是冰雾的天气
就拖着那个人
就往下跑
那时候已经来不及。
没办法让他就
缓着走
没办法缓着走
太危险了
当时我把剩下所有的金属。
包括我的合金登山杖。
就全部都丢掉
就避雷
然后就拖着他
就往下跑
因为当时是一个空点。
没有办法避雷
就只有
就有点天天有命的那种感觉。
然后就往前跑
你这还是有非常好的。
这种避险意识
对
真的
能做的不太多
但是必要的动作
还是要做的
然后就跑
大概是跑了
还是有很大一会的。
好
但是他在路上又是。
摔倒
掉到什么冰窟路上去。
然后又拖出去
躺在地上不想走了。
这一切都发生在冰雾里。
对
然后最终我们还是。
安全的出来
出来到了我的车
开着之后往下走的时候。
就看见我在那打档。
就带着一帮好手
你说后来是
走到终点了吗？
还是走到下一个不及点。
终点
走到终点了
什么路上什么人都没有。
没有人没有车
没有补给
这挺像
对
然后就拖着往下走。
我其实到了后半时候。
我已经不太记得了。
就只有一个意识
就是拽着他往下跑。
当时我形容就是
当时唯一的感受就是。
冰雾很密集
就是我的后背
简直就像被激光箱。
在扫射一样
打他他他
一直在打我的背
然后他什么感觉不知道。
就拽着他
就冲下来
冲下来之后
就送到我们之上
诊所里去
当时一查他的血氧。
就有40多
这挺危险
血氧是的都会很危险。
很危险
但是
还是一洗眼睛一会。
就整段人都恢复医生。
他都不知道自己怎么下来。
但旺你作为
从小就你说牧民生活。
对户外有很亲近
你是不是生活中
没有怎么遇到过
这种可能危险的情况。
还是说也有
其实我之前觉得
也不危险
我也遇到过类似的情况。
我们夏天
就是暑假的时候
我们也会去山上
挖一点背幕呀什么的。
去找一些草药
然后背幕
背幕
背幕就是中药
只壳的
对有一个
对对对
背幕
穿背包高里是不可能。
对
就他
然后我们去上山的时候。
也是会遇到这样的。
几段天气
我之前是
因为我们
我们村里面
也有人遇到过类皮啊什么的。
但是
我们也
就是没有多少那种。
怎么说的
户外这种意识
对对对对
就简单的话
就是自己身上的一些金属。
丢掉
我也亲
就是亲身经历过
就是快要类皮的那种。
头发都说下来了
那很危险了
然后我能说
一直在
一直在年纪
然后一直在跑
真的有点害怕
但是我后面就是
去学习了一些专业的东西之后。
就是后怕
有点后怕
然后就是
我觉得就是你真的。
不要觉得自己
怎么样很了解这个地方。
比如说那天
他那个什么？
就是
带过来的那个朋友。
可能他觉得他自己。
跑过很多地方
然后就是
你换到另外一个地方的时候。
又不一样
他可能就在内地的。
户外环境里面
有过这样的
跟宿船的这种经验。
但是换到高洋上
又不一样
所以就是
户外这种东西
你去玩的时候
必须要做足够的准备。
对
但是我看今年的话。
就是也心态放平
也不用去那么担心。
路上也有很多估计点。
还有医疗点
基本上没问题
大家该做的准备
做好的话
基本上不会有问题的。
对 你看你说准备。
咱们接下来
就反正聊了各种层面准备。
咱刚最开始
聊了很多高派的事。
这个算是一个身体上的准备。
刚才咱们又提到了。
一个心态的准备
其实心态的准备
我个人是觉得
我是觉得大家
如果要是想要去走。
某个线也好
完成某个项目也好。
尽量不要抱着那种说。
我一定要完成它
享受它
对
这就是包括
放到灯山上
有一种叫灯顶崇拜。
有一些人
他一旦有灯顶崇拜。
这个就很危险
对吧？
咱们把心态放平
今天的天气不好
咱们该下车就下车。
很多时候意外
就发生来说
就差50米的爬升了。
对吧？
所以说
你像咱们这个
高尔摩提这个线
也是
如果有朋友之后来了。
虽然知道你迁连条条。
又是休假
又是花钱过来
但如果真的是天气不好。
身体不舒适
咱们以后有的是机会。
果断下车
我觉得心态
这准备上
我觉得更多的心态。
放平
不要追求某个完成的。
那个标签
整体而言
这两年我深夜
因为要一日速穿
我深夜走这个
高尔摩提的时候
建廊的几率是50%。
虽然最后都全身而退。
但是我自己
对于这个充满情味的。
我今年觉得
真的是我幸运
可能也是马年
我第二次去赚
高尔摩提这个
深山接纳了我
他不为难我
否则的话
以当时我的那个
高反
或者那个身体的那种。
虚弱的程度
我要是碰见猛兽
我是绝对干不过他。
去年我还能干一干。
去年我虽然很疲惫。
但我没那么冷
我去年我还想过
如果碰见狼
真是过来
我是能跟他搏斗一下。
搏斗赢不赢
咱不说
我是有劲跟他搏斗的。
今年完全没有
这个是外赚
除了外赚之外
还有一个内赚
咱们一般游客
也就不用考虑了
尤其是今天
马年理论上
官方是不开放的
这个内赚
在当地藏民里面
在当地藏族同胞里面。
有个说法
就是你要外赚
赚购至少13圈之后。
才能赚内权
内权你可以理解为。
是一个离
刚人波棋
主山山地
更近的一个
赚山路线
距离更短
应该只有20公里左右。
但是
难度更大
海拔更高
更危险
据说
内赚的时候
真的是有人
经常会在路上
会遇险
甚至死亡
因为内赚
路线
它就不是纯走路的。
康庄大道了
虽然外赚
你刚刚听我说
也是有一些
难度的
又是爬升
又是翻牙口
又是高海拔
但内赚
我当时在网上
看过一些视频片段。
中间好多
我说到山体上
你需要拉着
之前别人
可能是
前人给你做的
一些辅助的铁链
或者是那种
哈达经藩的那种
你拽着走
你得拽着走
它很抖
也没有保护
是挺容易出问题的。
就跟大家
就普及一下
我估计
大家今年
至少肯定赚不了内赚。
大部分的游客
可能也赚不了内赚。
因为大家
通常认为
你要外赚赚购13圈。
你要信这个
有一定的
赚山经验之后
你才能去赚内权
就虽然这个规矩
特别像是一个
资格的筛选
但其实我觉得
他是有科学之处的。
我听说
这个之所以有这么一个标准。
也是因为
他要确认
你要赚购13圈外权。
就通常意味着
你有一定的体能
和对这个
户外的理解
你赚内权
才相对比较安全
然后还有一个路线。
这个就只是
顺便给大家克服一下。
当然完全不推荐大家走。
还有一个算是
一个D-Tour。
一个Shortcut。
一个捷径
叫空行母密道
大家走外转的时候。
走到天脏台之后
正常你就会
继续往前走
然后翻牙口
但是从天脏台
如果你往右
它有一个差路
你可以走一个
相对更短
但是也明显
更危险的道路
叫空行母密道
然后这个路线
咱们自己的
咱想都别想
我是自己
说实话
我这么爱冒险
我想都没想
因为这条线也很危险。
它是一个
没有固定路径的
这么一个大概的
一个Shortcut。
你要走这个空行母密道。
除非你自己
体能也很OK
然后路线也很熟悉的话。
咱都不说你又没有资格了。
你就是很容易出危险。
甚至可能很容易迷路。
所以说
跟大家普及一下
就是在外转的路线里面。
有一个空行母密道的Shortcut。
但是大家
了解一下就行了
千万也别去瞎走
很危险
然后聊完路线
跟大家聊聊这个装备吧？
首先
防风的冲锋衣
硬革冲锋衣是要有的。
其实我自己
不是一个冲锋衣的这个拥顿。
我自己老觉得
这些冲锋衣
被高估了
好多朋友
户外玩的不咋多
上来先卖冲锋衣
又很贵
其实很多时候用不上。
我自己在户外里面。
其实很多时候
我都穿用不上冲锋衣。
我甚至只要天气
要是没有大风大雨的话。
其实
保暖层是用最多的。
就是这个羽绒服
就是排过羽绒服
保暖层
有些人穿抓绒
其实就够了
除非你遇到这种大风的时候。
套个硬壳
软壳我也觉得用的。
用住不大
但是
如果你赚
刚才博起这个
赚山路线的话
我觉得冲锋衣一定得有。
就是硬壳
因为中间可能会起风。
天气要多变
然后
羽绒服
保暖层得带
我自己是比较喜欢。
这种排过羽绒服
很轻便
或者是比较保暖的棉服。
今年
像我去的时候
这个4月份
天还很冷
我的打底层
是一个羊毛打底
然后带了一件棉服。
一件羽绒服
一个硬壳
全部都套上
最后我都还觉得冷。
我觉得保暖层
跟防风层都要带好。
现在这个时间
那天我去走的时候。
我是穿了一个
你可以理解
秋裤
就是保暖裤
套了一个软壳冲锋。
我都觉得不够
很冷
我现在如果能重新选。
我一定会戴
再戴一条抓绒裤
或者羽绒裤
所以说就是
你如果去走的话
保暖层的衣裤
跟防风层的衣裤
是一定要有的
然后这个冬天的话。
你像我现在走
还有冰
那你就戴一个防滑登山靴。
甚至有些朋友
如果你要是想
戴一些荣誉
但是安全的装备的话。
你要戴一个冰爪
现在那个
翻做马拉雅口
还有冰呢？
但是等你过了
这么冷的天之后
就不用冰爪
就是防滑登山靴
甚至我建议
越野跑鞋就行
这几年
越来越多
之前登山靴的英雄场景。
被越野跑鞋给取代了。
因为越野跑鞋
本质上你就可以理解。
为是一个更轻便的登山靴。
对不对
因为它都有那个
防滑的这种
叫什么Vibram的。
这种Maggrip的大底。
它是防滑的底
然后它又更轻便
当然唯一的是
它可能
有些越野跑鞋
它为了轻便
它是透气
它没有那么防水
没有什么Gortax。
登山靴的好处
是它大
重
结实
支撑好
坏处也是它重
它比较耗费体力
我自己其实今年
走完之后
我特别后悔
没有穿个越野跑鞋。
它会轻一点
而且很多越野跑鞋。
相对做得会舒适一点。
比如缓震
它的底会软一点
你走五六公里
其实还是
脚底板挺疼的就是。
我今天穿的登山靴。
它好是好
但是登山靴
就是它结实
脚底板很硬
板很硬
最后走完五六公里。
我脚底板疼都不得了。
所以说
这个是鞋的一个推荐。
然后我个人会觉得。
你反正就是户外的装备。
那种户外的
徒步的厚的羊毛
可以在包里再戴一双备用的。
然后头上毛线帽
这肯定得有
然后那个护脸
天气暖和的时候
你戴个魔术头巾
戴脸上
挡挡沙尘就够了
你像天气冷的时候。
我是非常建议戴那种厚的护脸。
像是滑雪戴的那种护脸。
今年我也是
特别后悔
没有戴那个护脸
我非常冷
我被真是吹傻了
今年我19号走那天。
就是有些朋友
如果在当地就知道。
19号那天真的是狂风大作。
我朋友说
他们在那个山脚下直播。
沙尘吹起来能见度就没几米。
他说当然特别担心我。
我在山里倒没有那么多沙尘。
但是风特别大
这种时候就是你保暖。
从头到脚一定要坐到位。
尤其是肢体末端
比如说手套
因为我去的时候
我觉得我赶不上
25号开山
我以为我走不了
有些装备我没有戴。
我登山帐也没戴
手套其实我戴了
但是好像丢了一只。
我就是从那个
他二行酒店里去
转山的时候
我想拿手套
但我发现不到手套。
我只剩一只了
后来我就没拿
反正也用不上
我就没拿
没想到当时特别冷。
然后登山帐
我也是从酒店借的。
我想用登山帐
但是手冷
不用登山帐又累
最后我真的是选择了。
不用登山帐
当然这样拆起来了。
然后我就把手
一直一路拆兜里
我52公里有30多公里。
可能都是
我手是在兜里拆着的。
因为太冷太冷
当然除了这种
典型的户外装备
一般有户外经历的朋友。
都知道怎么戴
尤其是要提醒的
充电毛也得戴着
因为这一趟
路比较长
虽然你中间
要是落脚的话
这肯定有地方充电。
但是万一人多
充电毛我就还是戴着。
头灯要戴着
然后唇膏一定要戴。
西藏本来就干
阿里海拔更高
更干 非常干
类似于什么凡士林。
唇膏一定要戴
就是我没有见过
有人到了阿里
到了普兰之后
嘴不起皮
或者嘴唇不干的
再硬的硬汉
都要戴唇膏
真的
到了庚仁波吉
再硬的硬汉
都要戴唇膏
然后防晒霜
登山帐
强烈推荐要拿
戴一个保温杯
在高原
环界高反
很重要的一点
就是喝水
喝热水
今年我也是拖大了。
箱子有两个保温杯。
一个大的
就是我去户外常带的。
一个Mond Bell的。
一个一声的保温杯。
还有一个
350毫升的
一个小保温杯
今年
我也是不知道
我想这个清亮化
我就拿了一个
350毫升的小保温杯。
后来水也不够喝
而且杯子也不专业。
后来在不动地丁的时候。
它也坏了
我给升了
那个保温杯是我
24年录
喜剧之王单口迹的时候。
那个节目组给演员。
准备的杯子
然后还贴着
喜剧之王单口迹的贴纸。
还有毛冻这个名字。
被我扔在了不动地丁。
因为当日的不动地丁的时候。
它里面那个
橡胶垫
掉了
然后它就密封不了了。
水一直漏
然后如果你走的话。
顺便可以带一点这种。
简单的
药
或者创个贴
止痛药
腹瀉药这种东西
一般在户外
大家都是必备的
就是尤其是
你有一些相关的情况的话。
比如你肠胃比药脆弱。
你就带点肠胃药
啥的
确实
因为这条线
哪怕对于很多户外高来讲。
它整体还是一个强度很高。
海拔很高的东西
所以大家就是
能不带的
就别带了
轻一点
你说有
可能有高手
真的能背好多
无用的东西
估计是
少数的少数
你知道在我们
周末拉格下边
有很多垃圾桶
垃圾桶里面
经常会发现很多重装包。
成建制的物资
然后就在垃圾桶里面。
实在背不动了
就是
你看这个包
都能推测出
一个人物小转
这个老驴当年
是怎么觉得自己
肯定可以
所以说你真的痛苦的时候。
就身上
手上拿一瓶水
都觉得重
能不带就不带
你看
我觉得肯定要带了。
我来问你们几个
比如说
对于一般的
图部爱好者
因为既然他需要
听咱们的建议
可能就属于入门性的。
老手那也不用听咱建议。
不听了
背一个中手包就上去。
对
登山杖要带吗？
你们觉得
要带
必须要
双杖
为什么？
因为
你单杖的话
你自己的整个
身体的平衡性
包括你的接力
都会
不是特别好
从装备上来讲
我认为
图部鞋
你就从图到
头头到脚
第一个
冷帽要带
就是我们手说的毛鲜帽。
毛鲜帽
还有一个暖帽
暖帽
就是我们说的太阳帽。
太阳帽
暖的手要带
这两个你要有
然后要有一件防风的东西。
防风 防水的东西。
至于你是冲锋衣
还是什么？
这个根据个人条件。
去选
然后
保暖的
比如福
刚刚我们有小伙伴。
说GTJR
那可
那就是GTJR
和我们的5000 GT。
我职业里面的东西。
如果你有这两件
你不要去选择都戴上。
然后保暖到裤子也要戴。
这就是从装备两张图布鞋。
好的图布袜
一定就是这是一个图布最基础的。
它们必备的太阳镜有条件准备两袜。
是
袜子要两双
对
制造两双
我们制造山袜子要两双。
因为你第一天晚上。
换一下吧？
换一下第二天会舒服很多。
是
对
然后这个就是属于装备这一块。
有一些东西了
那至于说保厚啊？
什么这个提别程度啊？
这个就看天气
就是你要看你来的时候的天气情况。
和你真实当地的一些。
咨询的一些情况
我有个建议就是不要带棚画视频。
不要带棚画视频
是站地方
对
然后它保护感差
然后你身体所需要的东西。
它还补充不了
哎
这种
等于说这就是咱所谓的户外的路餐吗？
一定是你平时就喜欢吃的。
啊？
能吃下去
就是对
你自己就平时就是。
你就喜欢吃的
就比如说你就平时。
不喜欢吃耳根
你就上这儿来
就千万不要带
就是这个意思
是
然后还有一个就是坚果类的东西要带。
然后还有一个就是保护感强的东西。
就是这一类东西
就让你吃上时候
可以税缩有
所以说提供的能量很重要。
但是保护感也很重要。
保护感也很强
然后有条件呢？
可以带就是一两个小的水果。
那如果说你说我没有那么条件。
就是说背不动
背不动我带一个苹果。
那你可以考虑带一些苹果干啊？
橙子干啊？
这女友人喜欢吃芒果干。
那就带个芒果干
是
这些东西都是可以帮助你。
恢复体能的
就是这些
但是千万不要带那种。
就是消耗其他东西的东西。
就比如说
就有人会很极限的带这种。
类似于压缩饼
这样的东西
其实我不建议
不要这么急
我不建议
因为就是你吃这个东西。
才会消耗很多的水分。
然后比如说我们有的时候。
因为我也参加很多约约比赛。
就有的人会选择去带能量胶。
其实这个我也不太建议。
因为这东西没有很强的保护感。
它是很极限的帮你补充一些。
身体所需要的一些其他的东西。
大家除了自己带的之外。
也像我们在山上的午餐跟晚餐。
一般都吃
我吃的泡面最多
因为它就是味道多嘛？
然后你可以选你自己喜欢吃的。
然后去吃
然后晚上其实我们。
补级店有些像茶餐厅。
茶馆还有这个酒店。
茶餐厅一下干广东去了。
他的那个
藏餐厅
他的那个川菜其实炒的是很好。
对
我吃过的话
他甚至有可能比山下吃的川菜还要好。
所以说吃这个方面。
尤其是晚餐
你真的可以就认认真真地让老板炒两个川菜吃。
对
其实是很不错的
是
然后就第一天对吧？
对
然后第二天早上
其实大部分的茶馆都会提供你。
臟面
然后西饭
馒头
鸡蛋
其实你是可以进行正常的一个。
一个饮食的
对
没有那么艰苦
说到刚才上班长不是说。
蛋花要跟我们分享美食吗？
对
你跟我们分享
这一顿
那我先分享一下
我自己转山的时候吃什么？
就像我的话
咱们不是很好
所以我会吃的更清淡一些。
然后我会带一个酸巴。
然后倒酸奶
然后就吃那样的
然后我会路上还带一些酸梅。
就是梅肉之类的
这样口感的时候
酸的东西就是
对
就是酸的东西
能把那个味给激发一下。
对
是吧？
就其实跟果干到底是还是一样。
对
很有来
然后就是尽量吃清淡一些。
我们藏地的美食的话。
其实很多东西可能你们吃不惯。
我们的话就是
最日常的话就是喝酥油茶嘛？
然后这种的话
你们想喝的话
也可以看一些比较怎么说嘛？
就是比较怎么说嘛？
就是
你说有点翻译
当地的一些人
比较推荐的一些小餐馆。
就是味道比较正宗的那种。
然后也喝甜茶
我10年第一次来西藏。
那个拉萨不有很多茶馆。
那个茶馆当时说就是甜茶。
甜茶馆
其实那个时候大家当时就对。
西藏茶馆的时候
通常指的是甜茶
都指甜茶不是酥油茶。
对
但是甜茶馆这种东西就是。
在西藏
它不只是早上去喝茶。
就是满足这样的一个。
餐饮的一个需求
它是一个很有
也是感或者就是
很有体验感
或者就是社交上的。
对
社交的空间
就会
你哪怕不认识对方。
也会一起聊起来
聊起来怎么怎么样。
就是周边的一些
那个气氛很好
对
咱山上的茶馆都是这种。
随时跟隔壁桌聊天。
随时
几位
泳哥你先分享
高反这个事怎么解决。
或者预访
其实高反这个事情。
实际上
换一种角度来讲
实际上是人人都有的。
其实我们在前两天来的路上。
我们大家一起开车来的路上。
其实我们也能感受到。
是
我上过9000米。
在坐飞机的时候
铃行车
你这么一位
是的
铃行车就可以
其实这个代表不了。
你会不会有高反
是
其实高反会有很多种情况。
第一种就是
可能在我来之前
前面几天休息得不好。
吃得不好
可能都会有这个问题。
甚至于说有一些
比如说有一些
身体可能有一些威威的不舒服。
当你进入到高原
然后开始
发现
开始症状出现了
什么症状出现了
轻微的头疼
然后包括
就是可能感觉呼吸会有些困难。
有的人会恶心
我吐啊？
这些都属于是一些表现这种状态。
然后还有一个就是。
不是说我之前上过高海拔。
我就没有高海拔
当然大家都不要紧张。
就是你要有一个好的心态。
然后在你来之前
其实从你出发地
不管从哪儿出发
你都开始要进入到这个状态。
就是首先第一点保证什么呢？
冲突的睡眠
这个冲突睡眠指的。
就是你来之前
你就要有冲突的睡眠。
然后还有一个就是。
关注隐私
那有的人可能感觉说。
我就要控制体重
怎么怎么样如何
如果少吃一些某些东西。
我建议你要是想到高海拔。
来去自驾也好
或者徒步也好
就是你可以尽可能。
让身体多补充一些基础的。
一些东西
比如说精致的碳水。
然后一些水果
糖分都可以补充一些。
适当的补充一些
当然别使劲吃
然后在来的过程当中。
也可以逐渐逐渐的。
像我刚刚给大家讲。
你可以先去拉上西藏博物馆。
去看一下
指达导师看一看
对
光一光各种各样的街市。
看看夜市
对吧？
看上晚上
灯光照耀下的布达拉宫。
再看看日出的时候的布达拉宫。
就这些都是你适应的过程。
然后还有一个就是。
高海拔上有一个最重要的一个因素。
就是越早表现越好。
其实这两天来的时候。
我
毛泽东可能也能知道。
就是我们小伙伴
在前面一天的时候。
他感觉这一无所谓。
第二天感觉我还可以。
第三天的时候感觉不行了。
甚至于到第四天
第五天的感觉
不行 我要细养
原因是什么？
就是每个人的表现是不一样的。
但是大家并不要对这件事情紧张。
就是我一直跟那
很多小伙伴都在讲。
就来的时候保证自己多喝水。
是
首先多喝水
让自己的心存在一些。
让自己的整个的身体的状态。
能够尽可能的
进入到一个舒服的状态多喝水。
然后还有一个就是多做胜呼吸。
平时的时候自己也可以有些训练。
或者怎么样
就是能可以增加一些适当的一些。
不都说剧烈的运动。
增加一些简单的运动。
比如说简单的补步。
简单的走一走
然后自己让自己有一些感受。
然后最主要的就是心态要好。
千万不要因为
我是不是有高法拉。
或者说我可能会不会有高法。
不要去考虑这些
然后而且现在我们在沿途来的过程当中。
很多的医院
诊所呀？
包括西洋的地方
其实很完善
一旦出现这个情况。
大家不要心慌
是
对吧？
是可以通过西洋去缓解。
然后可以去做这样的事情。
是没有问题的
我没事
没事
那我接着泳哥
我也思想一下
因为我觉得我很有资格。
因为泳哥这一趟下来。
我看他主要是
他对高反健
更多的是一个过来人的身份分享。
我其实当事人
因为我这么多年
就是我签平均每年也都会上个。
五千米的高海拔登山。
我总觉得时间长了。
是不是我这个高海拔。
实际性就会好一点。
哎呦
但是很残贵
反正每次到了五千米以上。
都要有症状
都要有多好点症状。
那我自己的九病成一。
我跟大家分享这个。
你如果担心自己高反。
怎么办
先不要害怕
如果有一天你到了一个高海拔地区。
比如说你要来高尔摩基。
路上就有点头疼
难受
别说到头就回去
它是有很多方式
可以咱们去缓解
怎么那么糟
比如说
我最早被告知了
前辈能跟我说
多喝热水
这个最前一项是往上一个。
耿一样的这个四个字的建议。
在高海拔是非常非常实用的。
对
多喝热水
因为我后来查了一下。
它是确实
因为高海拔血液比较粘稠。
多喝热水能增加这个血液的这个。
减少的粘稠程度
从而提升它的摄氧量。
还有其实还有后边。
还有四个字
你说多喝热水
多上厕所
就是刚才勇哥说的。
这新人耐现
然后及时补充高糖的。
这种高能量的东西。
然后精致碳水
对
然后但是别吃太多。
这是我的一个
因为你到高海拔之后。
你自己想想
七分毛
七八分毛
七分毛是最好的
就是说
你刚刚吃完的时候。
感觉还可以
是
然后过了一两个小时以后。
感觉还会感觉有一点。
就是微微的有一种饥饿感。
这个是最好的
因为我们很多人都在关注。
其实高海拔
其实我们很多人现在都有这个。
我们西班牙人
每个人都有这种运动手段。
其实关注的就是两个东西。
一个是血氧
一个是心率
对吧？
你如果
心脏速度特别快
你的血氧可能就会出现问题。
原因就是因为你吃得太饱。
你的胃的消化也是需要血液的。
对
所以它就没有办法帮助你去呼吸。
帮助你去养的转化。
那就就把所有的血液。
都集中到胃上面
是
然后最终出现一个结果。
就是你发现你吃得很饱。
然后晕了
晕碳了
然后身体又不行了。
所以就吃得七分饱。
就可以了
然后不要去避讳说。
我不吃太水或者什么？
该吃什么吃什么？
到高海拔能量消化比较大。
对
这个时候多吃点
你接着说你自愈的经历。
因为我自愈经历是因为。
最开始我当时就是。
当时第一次上五千米。
去四姑娘的时候
我说OK
我说这高海拔还得干活了。
爬山
我说我怕我自己吃不饱没劲。
光光光晚饭吃得剧夺。
我说这得吃饱
但是后来我才意识到。
高海拔逼得七鸭有变化。
这个影响其实
你大家仔细想想
你拿到那个
你在平原地区买的小零食。
到了高海拔它不就胀了很大吗？
你有时候晒饱
你的身体内外的七鸭。
它有时候没有得到足够的适应的时候。
你吃很多
肠胃也会受不了
那天晚上我就记得。
在四姑娘大本营大单夜起来。
就上了所干啥了
很痛苦
所以说我觉得
不要吃太饱
这也是另外一个因素。
就是让身体的肠胃系统。
也要适应七鸭的变化。
内外是有一个体压差的。
就是去这种高山的时候。
有一些高原反应的话。
就是我们那边有个叫圆根的。
那你给我今天吃那个。
你要给我吃的叫什么东西。
就是圆根
早上我说
我有头有点疼
然后我把那个圆根拿过来。
你吃了
然后我说
勇哥你吃不吃
他
你吃没什么用
我吃着你
等会儿给你们看一下。
在我房间里
那个还是很有好处的。
然后像我的话就是。
这种高伤病
我觉得高原反应真的。
在医学里表达得特别好。
高伤病
其实我们牧区这种牵肠的时候。
也会有很多
也会有反应
对
就是牧区的这些人。
也会有这样的反应。
如果大家真的
准备来到高原
或者是说之前没有来过。
我建议先去医院
做一个基础的检查。
没有高原反应
对
然后还有一个最重要的。
就是我一定要提醒。
各位小伙伴们注意的。
就是千万不要乱吃药。
千万不要乱吃药
因为你吃了很多的。
你感觉
除非你有基础疾病的。
这种肠背样你要戴上。
就是你说
头疼我是不是吃了什么？
什么止痛的
或者是什么？
它是不一样的
最好就是说
你有感受之后
或者有一些其他不一样的。
你们可以准学一下。
当地的一些医生
或者是有经验的一些朋友。
然后根据你的实际的情况。
或者医生给你的建议。
判定去吃一些东西。
我建议你们发的话说一个。
一个是你刚才提到了红景天。
其实很多人对红景天有误区。
觉得它是吃高反的。
就是我出现高反中之后。
我吃了之后它是不是就好了。
其实它的正确使用方法。
就是是在你内地的时候。
然后你吃它
它会一直你的
血红细胞的一个抚养能力。
模拟高原环境
你吃了之后就开始头疼。
然后开始出现了一点。
所谓的轻微的高反反应。
然后你的身体适应了之后。
你再上高原
其实你已经适应这个环境。
所以说你说这个特别好。
它本质上是提前让你适应海拔。
它肯定虚假造出了一个假的高汉法。
很多人是来来之后有一点反应了。
然后就匡匡开始吃这个东西。
那海拔不是更高了。
对 结果会加重你这个反应。
这就是为啥
那个醒头说得特别对。
就有些朋友不懂
说吃红景天能吃高反。
当时有一个论调稍微正确点。
说这个不能离世吃。
提前什么三个月吃。
可能是你说这个原理。
只有一种性
比如说我自己吃红景天。
在现场吃的情况只有一种。
就是我去山上的时候。
或者我在阿里这边玩的时候。
我们其实这个草原上有很多。
野生的红景天
然后我没有水
然后我就会把那个红景天的液。
然后吃吃了之后它会补水用的。
但是它并不是只高。
爆点甜物
还有一个小的误区。
就是很多朋友的高汉反应。
其实跟感冒相似
就是头痛 流鼻涕。
或者是睡不着觉
这个是比较多的
这个时候很多朋友。
就觉得自己感冒了。
也会去吃一些感冒药。
但是你知道我们很多感冒药里面。
有这种脆棉成分
其实我们也是不建议吃的。
就是我们到了高原之后。
我的建议就是
你的任何不熟识
你都要往高坊上去想。
都是高山病那种体现。
对 都是高山病那种体现。
然后你去治高山病。
而不是去治你所谓的感冒症状。
明白
尤其是你到了我们山上以后。
一定不要吃任何神经。
除非你有这种基础病。
不要吃任何神经意志类的。
或者是在催眠作用的这种药物。
因为你要保持对身体的绝对的绝脂。
我头疼了或者是我怎么样。
你一定要把握这个身体的绝脂。
因为你一旦吃了药之后。
你本来头痛
然后我吃了一点止痛药。
我不头痛了
你就觉得你好了
然后你框框往上干。
然后就可能要出问题。
是
对
你头疼吃的受不了。
你就下车
就是这个止痛药
它有时候会成为你蒙蔽。
你对自己真正的状态。
身体绝脂的一种体现象。
对
所以说我也能不能理解。
咱们对大家一个比较。
真的是科学的建议。
就是如果时间允许的情况下。
就是利用自己的身体。
慢慢适应
适应
去环解高反
或者到最后走过
保护好这个过程
不要用一些
气球用一些复仇的方式。
做成的方式
这个是没有的
是
对
那关于高反
我还有几个想补充的。
太好
第一个就是
就体制的问题
你像勇哥这个体制。
看上去就不太像能高反的人。
对
那有很多人就说
那我是不是你越强壮。
那我就越不容易高反。
其实下下相反
就是你的肌肉还来越高。
你是一个肌肉男
那你其实来这个地方。
你的高反的概率会越大。
对
因为你的整个身体的。
叙扬量就越大
然后你就会越容易高反。
这也是为什么？
我们有很多朋友到我们咖啡馆。
从我们这儿出发去徒步。
对
然后越是有一些说。
自己是什么？
天生三相的高手
越也跑的高手
什么马拉松的各种冠军。
说我一天就轻松拿捏这种。
我们反而劝他
就你大概要慎重多适应几天。
因为我们这儿有个很纤纷的例子。
就是去年吧？
有一个越野跑的几届各种冠军。
然后过来之后
说那我今天我现在就中午出发。
你看我网上多少多少店。
我就回来了
然后他只跑到那个。
我们叫色熊广场
然后就喷射壮舞图。
然后就失去意识
然后就被人抬回来了。
他一下子就好了
然后几个小时就回到我们咖啡馆。
就非常沮丧地坐在那里。
对
但其实反而就这种。
平时爱锻炼身体的。
就越应该去注意
是哪个冠军过来认领一下。
然后再来之前的
大概是两到三周
就不要进行各种剧烈的运动和训练。
大概就轻微的进行一点。
有养血量
有我说的有养血量就可以了。
第二个点的就是
高反这种东西他有之后期。
就很多朋友到了我们这个海拔。
其实4600-4650。
其实是一个非常高的一个海拔了。
其实高反有4-6个小时的之后期。
那真正要命的时候。
比如你下午到了
你什么事都没有
然后很兴奋拍照玩吃吃喝喝。
玩睡觉的时候
我这高反就迅速就爆发出来。
是 谁费腾了
对 就很严重
所以说到这个地方。
你要一定要记住
他有4-6个小时的一个之后期。
你看你的心率
看你的血氧
然后安安静静的
把这段时间安全的渡过去。
不要去做太激烈的运动。
还不要太激动
对
不要半场开箱边
第三个点的就是在于。
像我们这个地方
其实早晚文山是很大的。
像我们自己的感受。
现在有阳光晒着你。
大概你的体感可能有十几二十度。
还是比较舒适
可是到了晚上
就是到了零下可能就十几二十度。
零下十几二十度
对
它的整个温暖是极大的。
你可能白天觉得特别好。
然后到了晚上你就忽视掉了。
没有注意保暖
然后没有注意一些基础。
而且温度下来之后。
就半分钟氧气含量的降低。
所以说白天你觉得很好。
反而到了晚
更应该晚上做一个准备。
比如说准备烈氧气。
或者是合理的休息。
转山的这些使用知识力。
还有啥呢？
尊重当地文化
对吧？
建议大家也顺时认转山。
还有就是转山的时候。
就尽量咱们自己
咱不乱人垃圾
我觉得你说有一些大家这个高反。
自身都难保
你说让你特地负重。
减垃圾可能有点难。
但是咱至少自己不争。
这个山上其实是有一些垃圾的。
也是因为咱们这些文化的隔阂。
像当地藏民
他没有现代非常先进的。
当代户外的一些共识。
什么所谓的Leave No Trace。
不要让垃圾
其实当地藏民想早年。
就可能之前没有这个意识。
所以说其实拓拓或少。
你路上会见到一些垃圾。
咱们至少自己不要乱扔。
有余力的话
你捡点垃圾走
那肯定是更是善莫大焉。
对
然后去阿里地区去纲人波集。
一定是要办编房证了。
这个东西
我也是去年去纲人波集才知道。
就是你去西藏不需要。
但是如果你要进入阿里地区。
进入普兰县这个地区。
是要办编房证
之前都是在各地
或者是在拉萨一些公安局。
然后你如果自驾的话。
路过什么日克泽
我去年是在路上
在日克泽去办的
今年是在拉萨办的。
但是4月15号之后。
已经在线上办了
大家如果之后要去纲人波集转山的话。
可以在线上办
具体怎么办
网上也得入攻略
你搜一下就知道了。
要办个编房证
这个是一定需要的。
因为它是边境地区。
所以说到时候来编地区。
编房证跟身份证
可能时常会被用到。
记得就是随身带好。
OK
我最后跟大家分享一下。
我这两年算是这个转山的一些。
刚才没有聊到的一些经验。
其实这两年转了很多这种。
个人经验或者是感受。
都在刚才这个化成为零的分享。
但是我现在最后回顾一下。
还有没有什么想说的。
我给大家先快速过一下。
去年我是早上类似于89点出发的。
然后中间因为是跟朋友一起。
又是拍照又是聊天。
又是补给在那歇
其实中间浪费了很多时间。
再加上最后他半夜的时候。
这个脚是旧伤不舒服。
还叫了救援下去
又帮忙又在那叫车等人。
又弄了很久
最后走完我走到凌晨三四点。
非常非常累
我在之前的基本无害里提过。
去年我走的时候
最后我一个人就走了有十几公里。
二十公里
二十公里里面
我是碰到了两次狼。
因为狼的眼睛反光是绿色。
当时因为晚上我就看到远处。
有那种像车灯一样的车。
在很快的开
我当时还在想
我说这个路远处有车吗？
有车道吗？
有高速公路吗？
有公路吗？
后来我才意识到
那个方向是纯闪
完全没有路
我才意识到
那个东西应该第一是野兽。
然后我当时也没有第一时间。
觉得它可能是狼
我想是不是野兔还是啥。
但是在去年的时候。
我后来见完狼之后。
我又见了野兔
感受到了一下野兔的行动轨迹跟速度。
然后我比较确定
我前段时间就是狼。
而且后面又见了一次。
离我更近了
可能离我有个一两百米。
但当时我很害怕
幸亏可能刚人过去的狼。
不怎么袭击人
当时那个狼绿色的眼睛跑得非常快。
然后在远处
而且我看的时候
当然有一段时间在盯着我。
我说这个是想告诉大家。
这个西藏真的是有狼的。
如果你要是走夜路的话。
一定要小心
建议千万不要走夜路。
甚至也是有熊的
但是这个我倒没见过。
然后去年我走了17个小时。
到最后那就是很疲惫。
但是当时我安慰自己。
我说我就是故意选择了。
叫断暂自己这种
长时间疲惫状态下行进的能力。
所以说我疲惫就疲惫吧？
去年我走的时候6月10几号。
但当时那个至少天气已经不错。
6月10几号走
我基本上穿的就是白天就是单一。
就是一个单的T-shirt。
然后翻牙口的时候冷点的时候。
和晚上的时候
我会套上一个排骨羽绒服务。
最冷的时候
我就再套上一个冲锋衣。
但基本上就够了
这是我去年走的这个状态。
大家都说这个翻牙口的时候。
可能是身体最痛苦。
但精神最崩溃的时候是最后4公里。
是最后4公里
就是你到了一个能走车的地方。
就是你到了中堆那个部级站。
中堆部级站
其实车就已经能过来接了。
你就已经到人类文明了。
你就感觉就差最后一多锁了。
已经走出山区了
你在那个中堆往那个小镇上。
塔尔清走的时候
你原来能看到塔尔清的那些楼。
路
店
霓虹灯
也没有霓虹吧？
就是灯
一目之所及
总感觉真的很近
但是那4公里
一般人要走一个多小时。
在平地上4公里
可能你走路也是不到1个小时就走。
但是你在高原上
尤其是最后走到50多公里了。
最后是很痛苦很痛苦。
对
然后转了几圈之后。
现在感觉
分开说
我认为就是最美的。
当然是很主观
这个美东西很主观。
我认为最美的肯定是。
有两段是连在一起的。
第一段就是这个
砖马拉雅口那一段。
短短的山脊
大概只有几百米
然后我无论是自己走也好。
还是跟其他人走也好。
这一段
几乎就是我最严肃的一段。
我都会比如跟朋友走的话。
就说那这一段我不陪你走了。
那这一段你在前面你慢慢走。
你用心的感受
你费劲千辛万苦
爬上了这段牙口
是一个什么样的感觉。
那这几百米的空间。
你自己慢慢走
是
那很多朋友走这一段的时候。
都基本上都会热烈的哭出来。
对
这一段我觉得是心灵上的震惨。
因为刚刚翻过
特别艰难的这一段路。
然后第二段就是
翻过砖马拉雅口
下面只有一个四碑湖。
那这个湖水
冬天是结着淡蓝色的冰。
然后夏天是深蓝色的一碗湖水。
就在雪山的黄沼之下。
是最美的一段
我认为最美的一小段。
对
然后这一段
然后你说男其实全身都男。
但最难的一段
无疑是最后四公里平平无奇的。
那一段小土路
甚至感觉已经走出山区了。
就已经在往镇上走。
就你已经走到走出山区了。
你不但能够看到那个镇的灯光。
你甚至能够闻得到镇上那个放滚。
飘出的香味
但是那平平无奇的四公里。
在一个半小时到两个小时的路程之间。
就是怎么也走不到。
就是天黑了以后
看得到闻得到就是走不到。
对
这一段其实挺折磨人的心理。
我跟
我这个走的次数没有。
行不得多
去年走的那一趟
同意
一个是
准把大家给我爬上去。
确实是身体
我不知道
如果有朋友说爬上那段。
全程无高反
那可能真的是你身体生得比较好。
我是当时
其他所有路程我都觉得没啥问题。
但是爬那段真的又开始累了。
身体很累
然后最后那几公里。
一样
我很同意
精神上很崩溃
但是某种程度也是一种。
就像你说的精神
精瘦反复垂大的一个过程。
然后我还有印象的整个点。
是
应该就是肘马拉拉有顶端。
会有很多人
就是在那留下自己一些亲人。
信念的这些
对
包括
不管是咱大家因为文化。
也留在这什么这种精烦也好。
还是大家出于个人的情感。
留下一些信念
这种照片等等
我知道
关于这个在山上
是不是要做这样的行为。
其实现在是有讨论的。
但是事实是
当我走到那看到这些东西的时候。
其实还是很感动的。
就是你知道
那边留下了每一个。
不管是相片还是某一个纸巢。
背后都是可能是很多滴泪水。
还有很多段故事
就是你当时就是我看到这东西的时候。
可能这些默讨的照片跟我。
完全在之前的时空没有什么交错。
我也不认识它
但你
就你说经历了那么多拔射。
看到这些东西的时候。
好像你们也在某种层面上。
有的有一些交集
对
这是我走这个路线的一些。
我印象比较深刻的点。
那我讲一下的话
就是刚出发之后
就是金方广场
那段路很适合拍一些。
短的一些视频啊什么的。
没有
你成摄影博主了这一话。
提供摄影博主建议。
大家走这一圈
反正很多人都很想。
有一些自己的视频嘛？
然后它后面都出来一些自己的。
留个气息
对
然后我觉得那里很适合。
然后大家要是第一天晚上。
在直儿四那边休息的话。
第二天就能看到
日照金山什么的
那也是很值得记录的。
但要说这个顺便跟大家科普。
这个是通常的两日。
形成的一个经典的驻足点。
直儿四
就是在直儿四停留的话。
第二天早上
你的视角是正好能看到日照金山的。
嗯对对对
正好是山的北壁
对
哎
我顺便不好意思等我插一遍。
因为你刚才说
这个是经典的两日路线的。
一个风格点嘛？
对
三日路线一般会在哪儿停的。
在往前走
就是过了不动地那个点。
然后再往前走
大概十几公里
有一个叫陈祖四
陈祖四
在那儿住一晚
对
OK
就所以说
其实有两个经典的。
两日和三日的方案。
对
其实官方给的一个指导建议。
就是三天
三天
就是直儿四
陈祖四
OK
不进
没有办法
但王
继续不好意思
打算是
没事
就是还有我自己走过的时候。
就是去那边的时候。
最难的路段跟情歌差不多。
就是还是琢磨拉压口。
还有就是最后的几公里。
兄弟
你上琢磨拉压口
你会感觉有明显的身体上的这种。
变化吧？
会感觉更累
有点喘嘛？
你应该实验得还不喘。
要有点
其实也没有
都是很难
但是最最重要的就是。
我看到
就是最后的几公里。
我看到了这个镇
然后我走过来
还是走了很长时间。
就很折磨
都一样
对
很折磨
而且走这个路线
真的
对于这种精神的魔力。
对
你说还有最苦
最讨厌的是什么？
就是你看的是平路。
它实际上中间有两个缓坡。
你一旦发现自己在走坡的时候。
就整个人还是有点不太好。
我去年走到那段时候。
因为我本来就是一天走完嘛？
当时前辈给的建议是说。
你就锻炼自己
再疲惫一下这个能力。
但是太疲惫了
我走到最后的几公里。
前面是城镇的灯光。
然后我真的是有幻觉。
我就感觉我前面有很多人的走路。
天呐
你没有遇到我
我感觉
当时我特别明显知道我那是幻觉。
就这些人是我
结果也只有你
就我自己
我都知道这是幻觉。
就是我感觉前面有些。
就是隐隐出了的人在走。
我现在说出来
感觉有点恐怖
但当时我的感受不恐怖。
我的感受就是我很累。
然后我有点幻觉
然后我在旁边看到说。
这边有好多兔子
我就拿手机去拍
第二天一看
顶上就是不动的石头。
就是在我
我以为那个石头我们就在赌。
那你已经是弯弯动的幻觉了。
对 当时确实太累了。
我给你讲一个
我们客人出现幻觉的一个例子。
就是他就走到最后这段路的熟悉。
就是凌晨两三点
然后那时候满天烦心。
满天烦心
他有段时间他就已经走不动了。
他直接躺在地上
他就突然看见这个星星。
就掉下来
整个星空垂下来
垂到他的鼻尖上去。
哎呦 这也是挺浪漫的场景。
然后他就听见一个声音说。
要继续走了
他都在躺着
然后他一睁眼
反正其实自己还在走路。
他并没有在躺着去。
他其实完全出现幻觉。
这是我去年走的时候的感受。
然后一路上碰到了非常多善意的脏足同胞。
我感受很深
会给你就是真的是。
脸上带着非常善意的温暖的笑容。
过来给你答话
普通话也不会说
大家就是语言声都不太通。
在那儿聊
他也给你塞糖的
塞吃了的
很善良
然后我自己是很喜欢体验当地文化。
我是从多年前第一次去西藏。
我就很喜欢去当地的茶馆。
跟当地人一样喝他们的甜茶。
酥油茶
甜茶你可以理解为就很像奶茶。
那个味道
酥油茶
你就可以列为咸奶茶。
这么说很简单了
然后甜茶
就是更多的是年轻的藏族人会多喝。
然后酥油茶是老辈子藏族人。
藏区牧民的传统饮品。
中年人老年人
他们喜欢喝酥油茶。
但年轻的朋友他们可能会尝点甜茶。
我觉得都挺好喝的。
然后你这一路上的茶馆。
我建议就是你可以点个一小壶。
他们的一小壶就是很老的那种热水壶。
带那种糖瓷内胆子。
一小壶多少钱
中壶多少钱
大壶多少钱
他们有些茶馆食安这种小壶。
大壶算的
有些食安那个二两什么几两算的。
我自己是到了
就是很喜欢就要一小壶。
不管自己喝
跟朋友喝暖暖身子。
而且你喝点那种热的。
也能环节高反
降低学的年轻程度。
提升血氧量
而且你还能顺便补充点热量。
这也是个很好的
我很建议的路上不计的方式。
然后网上有人说过。
说这个有夏天的话。
如果是夏天的话
你高反应不是很严重。
其实你甚至都可以不用带热水壶。
因为你带热水壶呢？
在补充店加热水
都是茶馆老板们
在附近那种河里接着冰川融水。
不是特别干净
常规刺的人可能不是特别喝的习惯。
说你还不如在店里之间。
买这种矿泉水
什么农夫山泉
当然天气就暖和点的时候。
像现在我想想天气逛的时候。
我当时就是误信了这么一个建议。
我就特地带了一个小暖水壶。
我想路上可以买农夫山泉。
但其实天气太冷
你买的水就很凉
还是得喝热水
但如果是夏天的话。
其实可以考虑不用带暖水壶。
你就带一瓶矿泉水。
然后每到补充店
就买一瓶新的矿泉水就行了。
其实我觉得合理
这个建议是也算是靠谱的。
然后今年走的时候。
我就我感觉这一年。
又多爬了很多山
多爬了很多约约跑。
我觉得我体能提升了。
然后高海拔适应程度也提升了。
自从当了国家二级动员。
爬了摩托塔格
我总感觉到高海拔。
总应该稍微更加得心应手了吧？
但没想到今年因为天气很差。
然后装备不够
我的状态比去年还差。
就装备了二口钱
我绝对比去年好
然后翻牙口的时候。
甚至刚开始翻
我都走得没有那么慢。
但是后来因为越来越冷了。
放大大大了
我极其的崩溃
所以导致今年也是花了。
这个将近20个小时才走完。
这成绩却说实话
一点都不值得称道。
就是很多人15个小时。
或以内就搞定了
但我也不修溃
因为今年确实特殊情况。
然后今年走的时候。
因为没有开山
人也不多
感受很好
在路上碰到人们
也才是那句话会很友好。
然后到处给你
路上会给你鼓劲
大家互相说扎西德勒。
互相用不一定听得懂的语言。
去送上善意
这气氛是很好
我唯一的体会就是。
如果有下一次
我真的不想一天走完了。
哪怕我体能可以
哪怕我不高反
我都不想一天走完。
我想好好地慢慢地走一走。
慢慢地走
慢慢地感受
哪怕在路上多停一停。
多拍拍照
多歇歇
多看看人
多观察观察
多在茶馆里做一个小时。
就坐在那
就当是走走歇歇
玩玩手机
喝点甜茶
真的
我建议你们要是时间充裕的话。
走高人波起最好这么走。
而且不要把时间拍得特别满。
你要给自己一些荣誉的Buffer。
比如说天气不好怎么办。
比如说如果你这个高反一下。
比你想象的严重怎么办。
你留下个一到两天。
至少万一出现高反的问题了。
天气问题了
你知道可以多等个一天两天。
要不然你完全没有一点溶错率。
你知道吧？
最后咱们送每一个。
可能会要来到
高人波起的朋友们。
送给他们一句我不知道。
祝福会建议
对吧？
都可以
要不从主持人开始。
主持人去
那我先说
那我确实
今天咱们主题很好。
说叫激发向往安全抵达。
我是希望大家能带着。
不要太过于滤镜化的向往来。
然后能够
真的带着平视的心态。
跟当地的这些藏族朋友们。
然后旅行者们
一块去体验不一样的。
风光跟人文
然后并且安全全的到家。
这是我的建议
对
那我顺着你说
那你是抵达这个实体的线路。
我是愿大家
能够抵达心中的高人波起。
上架指吧？
完了
你让咱们藏族朋友一下。
本来普通话就不好。
你这一弄一抽一样。
他说啥
用藏语说
你用藏语说
真的
我给大家说几句话。
我想起了一个
你是不是装的
师父传里面的一个台词。
叫什么？
刘博山东语的律奖。
但我表达不出来了。
反正就是奔照措
就是兄弟们
可能我可能怎么怎么样。
去不了了
就敬大家一杯
祝福你们
对
这个话有大概对应的藏语吗？
一个祝福的话
如果是藏语要说类似于。
祝你平安啊？
什么希望你安全回家这种话。
除了扎西德来这种祝福的。
还有什么话他是怎么说的。
其实这个恒火最近1376。
1376比较火
鸡三囤猪
也就是心想事成的意思。
1376就是数字1376。
大家都比较火
然后你看藏地的很多车子。
后面也有这样的数字。
山上还有1376茶馆。
为啥这啥意思
1376 鞋阴梗。
藏语的鞋阴梗
藏语
所以藏语读1376的读法是怎么读的。
鸡三囤猪
有点像心想事成的意思。
对
相当于1314
OK
1314就是医生医师。
就像这样的一个鞋阴。
可以
1376就是鸡三囤猪。
对
也是一个祝福
可以
这祝福很好
泳哥说个伟
我只希望大家能够完成自己的实验。
安全准备回家
OK
这一期本来我是想说的全面一点。
我其实也做了提供。
但是一不小心的也说多了。
而且说的可能显得也有一点点碎。
希望大家多多包容。
但是我相信
如果你真的对《刚人波棋》感兴趣的话。
这期节目应该是挺实用的。
最后还是建议大家。
如果有机会能去西藏。
能去阿里
能去《刚人波棋》看一看。
然后这条路线
因为这几年越来越火。
甚至有一些网红化的趋势。
这东西当然咱说不上错。
我还是倡议大家在这个路线上走的时候。
尽量还是享受自然为第一位。
不要因为一些过于网化的行为。
去干扰当地的这些藏族的朋友。
最后
之前好多集团会说。
去西藏能洗滌心灵。
走《刚人波棋》能够脱胎换股。
什么让你变成更好的人等等。
我个人作为一个不太追求这种。
浪漫化去世的人
当然不觉得走了一个五十多公里的路。
就能变成更好的人。
但是我觉得这个过程中。
只要你用心
他一定会给你很多启发。
他哪怕
不会让你立马变成更好的人。
他也会说不定
让你更了解自己到底是个什么样的人。
希望大家在未来有机会。
踏上《刚人波棋》转身路上的时候。
都能够享受这个旅途。
都能够获得美好的体验跟收获。
好吗？
最后也再次感谢凯勒时。
能够做这么一次有意义的。
就是近乎于行为艺术的。
这么一个很浪漫的直播活动。
忍肉把这几个嘉宾。
晕到《刚人波棋》山脚下。
去做的一个直播制造这个内容。
然后因为有这么一次直播。
才能让我根据这个直播的内容。
有动力
有表达欲
又多补充了一堆
我自己的这些感受跟经验。
让这些节目得意出现。
好了 朋友们
咱们就这么说
咱们有机会户外再见。
如果你喜欢这些节目的话。
欢迎留言评论点赞。
跟我们互动
也欢迎加入我们基本无害的听友群。
可以加基本无害的小助手。
微信号是基本无害2024。
它会拉你进群
好吗？
这周的咱们的这个步更到此结束。
咱们下期再见
拜拜